Just press the music.
Let's just go right with music.
We have no uh,
no commercials today.
I like it.
Golden.
What?
Commercial Free Ladies and gentlemen for
brought to you by the universe.
Okay.
Experience Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Ladies and gentlemen,
a very special episode podcast,
sponsorship free,
Dennis Mckenna and Josh Twickenham.
Josh is from the Ethno Ethno Botanical
Stewardship Council,
one of the founders of this.
And what exactly does that mean for
folks who have no idea what ethno
botanical or stewardship means?
A lot of people struggle with counsel.
It sounds like you're counseling people
and ethno botanical stewardship.
Look,
imagine bringing that up at a party.
Well,
the ESC is dedicated to transforming
lives through assuring the safety and
sustainability of traditional plants.
So that means a trans transforming
people's lives through experiences with
plants.
But it also means the sustainability of
plants and the safety in their use.
So we're starting with Iowasca and uh,
it bogus.
Yeah,
you should.
You shouldn't start with like ferns.
People don't get excited about a,
it's hard to get eucalyptus.
People really want to get fired up about
that.
But Iowaska,
anything involving tryptamines for folks
who've experienced it,
it's something worth saving.
Exactly.
You guys find it odd that in this day
and age,
in 2014,
the average person who you would go up
to to try to discuss these issues with
would have no idea what you were talking
about.
Actually,
I think over the last few years that's
kind of changed.
A IOWASCA is emerging into mass
consciousness and I think that's,
that's a good thing.
I would say 10 years ago,
15 years ago,
if you approach the average person on
the street and you've said Iowasca,
they'd look at you like you had a speech
impediment or select,
but chances are people would recognize
it now and not in necessarily know what
it's about.
Not necessarily have a negative or a
positive view of it,
but the meme is out there and I think
that's a good thing.
Ultimately it's most certainly a good
thing.
I agree with you.
That means it's certainly out there with
young folks.
But with folks,
um,
I'm 46 of folks my age and older,
it gets a little sketch,
you know,
it's like,
wait a minute,
what,
what are you doing?
Folks who already have mortgages and
families?
Those are the ones that's very difficult
to get them to even consider what you're
talking about.
You'd be surprised the ESC has sent out
a call for experts and we've been until
infiltrated by the mainstream people
that do evaluation work for the World
Bank and USA id.
They're interested in Iowasca.
People are going down to south to have
these transformative experiences to sit
in ceremony.
There's a lot of underground activity in
the US as well in Europe where it's not
legal,
but in South America and Peru,
Iowasca is protected as national
patrimony.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So beautiful.
Do you ever worry that you're being
infiltrated by government agents who,
uh,
who would want that?
I mean,
I'm not doing anything illegal.
We're working in countries where Iowa
Ska is,
has been used for hundreds of years
traditionally,
and we're looking at increasing the
safety of it so that we're creating a
kind of self regulatory model.
So that we can take that model to places
where it's illegal and say this is a
totally safe medicine if you do it
right.
People with certain medical conditions
shouldn't take Iowasca,
but uh,
done with a skilled curandero or shaman
in the right setting.
It can,
it can be helpful for all sorts of
psychological issues or ptsd or
depression and just give people a new
perspective on their lives.
Most certainly.
I mean,
I'm completely joking around,
but what I was saying when I was like,
you know,
that hasn't happened with marijuana
marijuana is they're still fighting it
tooth and nail despite all the evidence
that it's not just beneficial but
probably prevents a lot of cancers and
does a lot of fantastic work with ptsd
and with anxiety and all sorts of
issues,
medical issues,
you know,
interocular pressure for people with
Glaucoma and you know,
on and on and on.
People with aids that are having a hard
time keeping their appetite up.
Cancer patients,
I mean it's still,
they fight it tooth and claw and Iowasca
is a completely different barrel of
monkeys.
WASC is coming at this through the back
door and I mean it's interesting that it
has gained recognition over time to the
extent that it does and to a certain
extent I would say it's,
you know,
Josh,
people like Josh and me,
we say we work for the plants,
right?
And ios has got its own agenda
interestingly,
and people go down to South America and
they have these experiences that are
regulatory and self transforming,
but often they come back with an
enhanced ecological consciousness and
enhanced awareness of the connection
between humanity and nature.
The idea that nature is threatened.
And I think if Iowasca is sort of a
messenger from the community of species
that's trying to,
you know,
tell the the,
these monkeys to wake up,
you clowns,
you know,
it's,
we're coming down to the wire it,
we're in a crisis here.
You've got to really understand where
you fit into nature and do what can be
done in the ever shrinking time that's
left.
So people come back with this renewed
sort of awareness of the
interconnectedness of life and that we
have a role in this.
You know,
we primates and we have to really
understand what our role is as,
as stewards of nature rather than
exploiters of nature.
And I was,
you know,
that's the message that delivers to many
people and unexpectedly they may not be
going there to,
uh,
you know,
to experience that.
But that's what they come away with.
From your work and from your brothers
work.
Terence Mckenna,
what,
what I got a that I'd never considered
before was that psychedelics in,
in various forms may very well be
responsible for why we are human beings
in the first place.
And our separation from them might be
the whole reason why we're so haywire.
Why we're missing a crucial ingredient
involved in the creation of cognitive
thought in the first place.
The creation of this ability to look at
ourselves and communicate our ideas and
really become a human being.
And then we were separated from the
mother and left to our own devices and
all of our wild animal instincts sort of
take over and our animal instincts sort
of don't coexist peacefully in this
weird world that we've created as human
beings.
And then we create chaos because of it,
because we can't see what we're doing.
Right.
IOWASCA allows you to see what you're
IOWASCA.
Yes.
I asked her refocuses the whole
understanding.
I think of the relationship that we have
that we have to nature.
And I think that's what,
you know,
if you believe in plant intelligence,
I mean there are different ways of
looking at plant intelligence,
but it's,
it's interesting how often people,
you know,
they come out with this renewed
understanding and I think that's,
that's,
you know,
a desperate to call on the part of the
community of species and Ios has been
delegated to be,
to kind of lead that conversation.
It's fascinating that Iowasca is the one
that's been in the forefront when
mushrooms are so damn easy to grow.
You could,
I mean anyone can essentially get ahold
of some spores and start cooking them in
your basement like really quickly.
Whereas IOWASCA is probably the most
complex common atory beverage that we
know of as far as like psychedelic
bruise.
It's the one that requires the most
knowledge.
It's the one that requires the most care
and creating.
And it's easier to extract DMT and than
it is to create iom and get all the
plants and brew it together and know
someone who really knows what they're
doing,
how to cook up a good batch.
It's weird that that's the one.
Yeah,
it has its.
I think it's because it is so
interesting.
You know,
it,
it's escaped from its home in the Amazon
and that's the area on the planet with
the greatest bio diversity and all that.
But it's got all those associations,
you know,
people regard it.
I mean mushrooms are also important,
but they just don't seem to carry that
same.
I don't know what it is.
Emotional kick Iowasca gives the one
right now that's getting all the
attention,
you know.
And,
and it's quintessentially a plant.
Mushrooms aren't plants,
so maybe that's part of the disconnect.
I'm not sure.
But you know,
all of these things in indigenous
cultures are regarded as plant teachers.
And,
and as you mentioned,
a lot of it comes down to trip to being
chemistry.
And you know,
our brains for some reason are
evolutionarily prime to react to
tryptamines.
I mean,
we have these tryptamine detectors for
some reason and I think it's partly that
we can,
so that we can receive and interpret
what they're trying to tell us and what
they're trying to tell us is there's not
much time left and we have to really,
really understand our relationship to
nature.
We have to realize that we're not
separate from nature.
Well,
you're trying to overcome at least 2000
years of Judaeo Christian history.
And,
and you know,
the,
those traditions,
they're 10.
Their whole agenda in a certain sense is
to devalue nature.
You know,
nature is something that we own.
It's there for us to exploit.
It's up there for us to rape.
And,
and we're busy doing that because,
you know,
my,
my problem with those religions is the
focus is always on the afterlife.
So it tends to make you devalue this
life.
It makes you,
uh,
you know,
it,
it teaches people to devalue nature,
to devalue their bodies,
to devalue personal experience,
uh,
all of these things.
And that leads to the very out of
balance situation that we have going.
And uh,
you know,
what's,
what's disturbing to me is that we're
all part of this circle of,
of the converted.
I mean,
we,
we got the memo,
you know,
and,
and the meme is spreading,
the memo is spreading,
but I'm not sure it's fast enough.
Do you think that it's possible that the
human race is essentially cramming?
You know how when you're about to do a
test and you put it off till the last
minute and then you know,
the day before you're like,
Holy Shit,
I gotta deal with this.
And then you'd go bananas.
You'd taken adderall.
You filed through books until your head
wants to explode.
That is a characteristic that's very,
very common for people that want to
attack a project.
Especially an important project.
It's almost like we have this thing
where it has to be completely
overwhelming where it can't be ignored.
And then we go into it full throttle.
Is it possible that the human race is
and that maybe part of our self
destructive tendencies are actually us
recognizing that we're fucking up and
going into it more chaotically,
more materialistically,
more shallow,
more nonsense,
more Kim Carr,
dash in more American idol,
more horse shit just to get you to the
point where you get so sick of it,
you,
you puke it up and then move on.
Yes.
Yeah,
and we're in the middle of an ecological
crisis and time is running out and we
certainly are cramming.
We're,
we're destroying the Amazon.
We're destroying the climate.
We're destroying
the ocean.
We're destroying the air.
We're destroying everything.
We get our greasy little hands on,
and this is the first time in the 500
years of European colonization of the
Americas that there's a kind of reverse,
a reverse sort of message coming from
the Amazon.
People are going there not to convert,
but to be converted,
to learn to learn the traditions and the
indigenous people.
Ninety five percent of their population
was wiped out by viruses or wars or
plagues.
And,
and now we have this opportunity to come
back from the brink and work with
Iowasca that grows in the canopy of the
rain forest.
You can't have Iowasca without the trees
and it's so it's an alternative to
mining and oil exploitation and there's
money to be made in it.
And I think coming back to cannabis,
the reason the dialogue is starting to
change is because governments are
realizing there's a lot of money to be
made.
Taxation.
It's a solution to budget crises.
Um,
and the same with Iowaska tourism.
I don't like to say tourism because
people are legitimately seeking a
spiritual experience.
Some people just want to go have an
experience,
but yeah,
assuming wrong with the word tourism.
But I know what you're saying.
Like the frivolous.
I think it does.
I think we,
you know,
I,
I think I asked it,
tourism is a beautiful way or a
pilgrimage.
Yaps is [inaudible].
I think that tourism is a,
is a phase in our relationship to
Iowasca.
I think that I think that potentially if
we couldn't,
you know,
what I view is going on now is kind of a
rough period.
But what is really being played out here
is the co-evolutionary relationship with
these plants that have gone on,
as you say,
ever since we became cognitive beans.
In fact,
it was the plants that triggered that
and now and that conversation is going
on and that,
but now the conversation has gone to a
new level where Iowasca before was kind
of,
you know,
the,
it was under the stewardship of
indigenous people confined to the
Amazon.
Now it's circling the globe.
And I think this is partly,
this is what plants do.
They like to spread and they're
spreading out into different cultures.
And the plant itself is now,
you know,
even if the Amazon is destroyed,
which it may well be,
I ask is not going to be destroyed.
It's too late.
It's already escaped.
But I think,
you know,
hopefully we can arrest this process.
But,
uh,
what you're seeing is,
has always been a evolutionary
relationship where,
you know,
at some time,
some points it's more quieter,
it's underground,
but at some point says as the crisis
deepens,
it's becoming more and more public in a
sense.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I think that's what you see going on,
you know,
and,
and potentially I think that Iowaska,
you know,
we're now discovering that it's good for
so many things,
you know,
therapeutically for addictions,
for depression,
for ptsd and that sort of thing.
And that's all to the good.
But we shouldn't make the mistake of
thinking Iowasca is only for sick
people,
you know,
it's,
we're all wounded and we all need to
understand something about our
relationship to nature,
potentially the paradigms that are
emerging in Ios get tourism or these
more,
you know,
these eyewash gets centered spiritual
communities in the states.
Potentially this has the,
uh,
this may transform mental health care in
this country.
It may transform psychiatry and from
that it might transform medicine and it
might actually transform all these other
institutions that we have to deal with
whose values have become twisted over
2000 years of,
of bullshit and,
and indoctrination.
Uh,
you know,
these institutions are not going away
and they're fine.
They just need to rediscover a moral
dimension to the consequences of their
action,
if that makes any sense.
You know,
uh,
our cleverness far exceeds our wisdom
and that's a problem.
That's the problem we've got to become
wise and when we couple that with our
ingenuity and our cleverness,
them will be on the way toward saving
the planet,
saving ourselves.
I think there's also this growing
understanding of all the factors that
encompass a healthy person and how many
of them have to do with your conception
of reality.
How many of them have to do with the way
you think,
how many of them have to do with how you
view your environment.
If you view your environment as hostile,
stressful,
antagonizing,
angry,
negative place,
you'll get sicker and your body fight.
It doesn't know what to do.
It's fighting it constantly and you're,
you're in a battle and you're all
stressed out and you're susceptible to
all sorts of things and they're in.
In that sense,
there's a direct physical between
psychedelic experiences and improved
health and that's something that people
really need to understand.
And I think once that catches route,
once people grasp that concept and
understand the incredible pressure,
alleviating alleviating properties like
our.
I can remember one of the first times I
ever did DMT,
the,
the day afterwards,
like I had this completely different
view of the world that I had to sort of
apply now all these other and like
figure out like do all these,
the,
these factors that I've considered as
being important,
how many of them am I going to throw
out?
Like the way I described it as like my
computer rebooted and now only has one
folder on the desktop and that folder is
labeled my old bullshit and so now I
have to open this folder and go,
okay,
how much of this is valid?
Like Jesus,
this is my whole thought process.
This is my whole mind.
This is how I interface with reality.
Unfortunately some of it made its way
back in,
you know,
and then you know,
I had to do another trip a few months
later and then I threw out more of it
and it was a sort of a,
a,
a deliberate process of reevaluation.
You can't reject it.
All
good stuff in that folder.
But I think what the DMT experience,
the psychedelic experience does,
you know,
that's partly what it does.
I like your analogy of the folder
because now you're looking at the folder
from the desktop.
You're outside the folder,
you know,
so it's liberated you,
you were imprisoned in the folder
before.
Now you can look at it from the outside
and you can go through and say,
oh,
you know,
delete,
oh,
this is good.
Let's keep this,
you know,
let's integrate it.
So,
uh,
you know,
ultimately this is a process of a
personal cleansing both physically and
emotionally and psychologically and your
encounters with these things,
but also cultural cleansing.
You know,
I mean,
there are,
there good memes out there and there are
good things going on,
but there's,
you know,
there's so much noise,
there's so much bullshit.
It's hard to sort out what's worth
preserving and what needs to be
dispensed with.
I think we're also kind of trapped in
this weird world of our creations as far
as technology as well.
I think that technology,
just like corporations,
just like anything that sort of becomes
a force that's constantly growing,
it becomes a,
it has a certain self preservation,
a aspect to it,
and I think that we're completely
connected to the idea of constant
innovation and constantly improving
technology and that also is completely
connected us to materialism because
materialism is the real driving force
behind constant innovation.
If we all just looked at our laptops and
said,
I'm good,
are you good?
There's no need to call apple right now.
Hey,
these are fucking great.
Stop right there.
Right?
You literally don't need to improve
internet speed.
You don't need to improve the laptop.
Everything's wonderful.
Let's stop all this and let's move on to
something else.
Well,
that's not what everybody wants.
Everybody wants the newest,
latest,
greatest,
fastest dual video processor.
I want to screen that roles and folds
and.
But that's part of the trap.
Yes.
This idea that we have to keep upgrading
to the iphone 10 or whatever.
I mean,
these tools work and there and it in the
proper way,
uh,
they can be tremendously important for
consciousness,
evolution and transformation.
That's what the psychedelics are,
they're just tools.
There are kind of technology and like I
say,
often to my classes and they'll
elsewhere.
Technology in itself is neither good nor
bad.
Drugs are neither good nor bad.
These technologies,
it's all about how you apply them.
That's where the moral dimension comes
in.
That's why,
you know,
you can use,
you can misuse technology,
internet technology to,
you know,
propagate whatever the Kardashians are
doing lately over the Internet.
But you can also change hearts and minds
with,
with those tools.
Like for example,
uh,
you know,
this live streaming symposium that
we're,
that we're involved with that were our
mandate is to plug this thing.
But it's important.
You know,
this conference coming up in Amhurst is
just one example.
Amherst,
Massachusetts amherst.
Oh,
I know it well.
It's Capitol of Massachusetts.
Perfect place to do this symposium
that's coming.
That's going to be live stream people
should go to.
It's a cute name,
symposium,
p s y m p o s I,
u m,
and it's going to be live streamed.
And if you go to the website,
uh,
you couldn't sign up for tickets for
live streaming at one more time for
people that were struggling.
Posey,
m,
P,
s y m p o s I,
u m cute,
right?
Yeah,
I'm hard.
I'm posing them.com.
And if you go to their website,
what you're going to see right now,
which I had nothing to do with.
You're going to see a little trailer for
live streaming and streaming and it's
actually,
it looks like a stealth advertisement
for my new product coming out,
which is the Dennis Mckenna bobblehead.
I'm in this trailer and I looked like I
have a movement disorder or something.
Then,
you know,
let,
let.
And why do you,
why does it look like you have a
movement disorder?
Let's,
let's play it.
You want me to play?
I know we're playing it right now.
Okay.
Go to full screen.
You'll see what I mean.
I was,
I just looked at it this morning and I
thought actually this bubble hand ideas.
What's going on here?
Let's see.
I'm just bouncing Hamilton.
Maurice,
how high was the person who made this
pretty high?
Pretty high.
This is,
he just made it last night.
I looked at it this morning and I said,
seriously,
she really liked this to be on your
whole page.
There it is.
You know,
the important thing is get past the,
the,
uh,
the trailer and you can,
you can sign up for this symposium,
which is these guys,
these young fellows of NAM pursed are
really enthusiastic and good,
good people.
They want this conference to have an
impact and I think it will.
Amherst is one of the few places in
Massachusetts I consider living.
I got familiar with it.
It's great.
It's A.
Yeah,
I've heard it.
I had an ex girlfriend who moved out
there when I was in high school and I
used to go out there and visit her.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I remember thinking,
Whoa,
this is like a totally different world
out here.
It's all like birkenstock wearing
strange hippie openminded.
Right?
It's just a weird,
sort of a strange place in the middle of
western Massachusetts.
Western Massachusetts is a strange place
in and of itself because you have Boston
w,
which is a very big city,
a very educated,
more colleges per capita than anywhere
else,
but then as you get out of
Massachusetts,
you might as well be in Kentucky for
about an hour and 20 minutes and then
you get to this weird oasis where like
the the woods part and then you know,
you have this strange place in amherst
was really highly educated and open
minded liberal community.
Well,
I'm not sure I've ever been there,
but I'm looking forward to this
conference.
You did enjoy it.
A lot of fun.
Yeah,
it really is the perfect place.
It's very much like a very small Austin
in the middle of of Massachusetts,
but with no music,
not as much music.
The guys organizing the conference
really are working with the plants and
for the plants and you don't have to go
there to participate.
The the beauty beauty is this,
this live sign up for 10 bucks.
You get a screening of neurons to
nirvana a great film and access to all
the presenters and interview.
Have you interviewed or shown neurons to
Nirvana on your.
No,
I mean it,
you know,
from a technical point of view,
I'm not a filmmaker,
you can criticize it from that point of
view,
but as an educational tool for
psychedelics,
I think this is really an interesting
movie and it's the kind of thing you can
sit down with your parents and watch and
they will come away.
Maybe some of their assumptions will be
shaken,
you know,
I mean,
it's a very good educational tool for,
under the subtitle is understanding
psychedelic medicines and it's
entertaining,
done.
And it's a kind of a review of the
cutting edge research on a,
bout four or five psychedelics,
Mtma,
Lsd,
mushrooms,
Iowasca,
uh,
and where the state of the art research
is on that.
And these,
these,
these chemicals.
You know,
what we need to do,
as we were talking about before,
we need to change hearts and minds.
I know it's a Cliche,
but these chemicals under the right
circumstances are actually a way to do
that.
And coupled with that is education.
Education is so important and that's
kind of the vision of these gentlemen,
Brett Green and the and his colleagues
that,
you know,
symposia like this are an important
component of this because it's a way of
getting the information out and the more
people that can be gotten out to,
the faster the change can be.
Can Be implemented.
Yeah.
They.
The change hearts and minds is an
interesting cliche because we've heard
it so many times.
It's almost like we've heard Wolf Wolf,
Wolf.
There's wolves,
there's wolves.
Holy Shit.
There's a wolf,
right?
The first time I did any psychedelics,
the first major one besides Mtma was
mushrooms and then that was my first
experience like,
oh my God,
there's a wolf like this is.
This is a totally different thing.
This isn't something that you have to
believe in.
This is something that's unavoidable,
right?
Doesn't matter if you believe in it.
Exactly.
He doesn't care if a parent for it to,
well,
you can't be.
I really don't think you can be.
I think you can be.
The best you can be prepared for is to
give up.
Just let it go.
Don't fight it.
Being prepared for that.
Take a few yoga classes,
know what it's like to be uncomfortable
and keep breathing and then just then do
it and then listen to it.
Surrender to us.
The message is there.
Yeah.
Will.
You said earlier,
which is a very controversial but oddly
fascinating thing that plants are the
reason why we are human beings today.
Why in these plant medicines and these
these psychedelic compounds,
w why is that so controversial?
I find that to be incredibly amazing.
When I talked to really intelligent
people and I bring that idea up and they
dismiss it like almost instantaneously
and I don't understand why because I get
it,
that they're connecting the idea of a
drug to a bad thing.
I get that,
but when you want to talk about powerful
influences on cognitive thought,
is there any more powerful influences on
cognitive thought than a psychedelic
drug?
I don't think there is.
I think I.
I don't understand why that wouldn't be
immediately considered at the top of the
list,
top of the short list,
but it's not.
It's Harrison.
See,
that's the thing.
It's an unconventional idea.
I mean,
if you look at,
you know,
we as a species,
we evolved in the rain forest initially
and we evolved in an environment of
incredible chemical diversity,
you know,
and it's absurd to assume,
and the reason they're such chemical
diversity in the plant kingdom is that
they're great chemists,
you know,
and they make all these chemicals for
whatever purposes.
That's how plants mediate their
relationship with their environment,
right?
They,
they substitute biosynthesis for
behavior.
This is what I say,
this is a cliche.
They can't react to their environment
through behavior.
They can't run away,
they can't fight.
They fight through chemistry.
At,
on the other side of that coin is we are
chemical systems.
I mean,
I hate to break it to you folks,
but we're made of drugs,
right?
That's why drugs work.
We're biochemical engines.
Our brains are biochemical engines that
run on neurotransmitters.
These plant compounds are our
neurotransmitters essentially.
I mean,
you know,
they were in plants a long time before
they were in our brains before they was
even complex brains of fte utilize these
things and are,
you know,
in the course of evolution,
we internalize these things,
have adapted them to our own,
like internal signaling processes.
So now we have the,
you know,
the neurological tools if you will,
to talk to the plants,
you know,
they've always been talking to us.
Now we can actually have a conversation
and the ca you get into the conversation
and the conversation is,
you know,
uh,
you monkeys need to move to the next
level.
You need to get more conscious of your
place in nature,
our place in nature as a species.
A realize that we're not separate from
it.
We're part of it.
And if it goes down,
we go down.
I mean,
there is no,
there is no escape.
There's no ticket out of here.
I'm not yet see any way and,
uh,
and the plants or the tools to
understand this,
you know,
I mean,
there's good scientific studies now that
show that silicide button,
which is the one that's been studied,
can reliably induce a state that you
might call a mystical experience.
I prefer to call it a transcendent
experience,
but the,
you know,
the nugget of the experience that it can
elicit other,
the right experiences.
This is an understanding of a,
we are all one,
you know,
we're not separate.
That's the core of the,
I think the mystical insight that
psychedelic spring about why should our
brains even have evolve to have that
kind of experience if it's not a way of,
you know,
kind of a,
I don't know,
uh,
being able to initiate that conversation
with,
uh,
with the rest of species.
I mean,
they're counting on us,
you know,
because never before we've civilization
and humanity is impacted nature and
adverse ways.
As long as we've been around,
as long as we've had fire,
you know,
fire back in the Paleolithic and even
earlier was a tremendously,
not necessarily destructive force,
but it was a transformative force on
ecosystems.
We didn't particularly use it in a
conscious way.
We we used it in a way that that served
our,
our purposes a,
but now with 7 billion people on the
earth and counting and technologies that
no one ever imagined that we'd have at
our fingertips.
What we do now really matters.
You know,
because we,
because before that nature,
the homeostatic mechanisms that tended
to take nature,
keep nature in balance,
you know,
we could cause tremendous ecological
destruction and nature with eventually,
you know,
that would fade away in nature would
come back into balance.
Now we're actually in danger of
permanently screwing up those mechanisms
so we actually have to kind of
consciously intervene or be conscious of
what we're doing because the
consequences of what we do are just so
much greater.
Does that make.
Oh,
it absolutely does.
It absolutely does.
I think there's another thing that we
need to put into perspective is the
relatively short amount of time that
human beings have had access to the
information that we have today and the,
the,
the terrible effects of propaganda and
how long propaganda can stick.
You know,
when we're talking about just the just
say no era of the eighties,
the Nancy Reagan nonsense.
I had Dr Carl Hart on recently who's a
brilliant dive.
You aware of his work,
amazing work on,
uh,
addiction and,
and,
and sort of educating people about the
actual real reactions that the human
body has to drugs.
But what he's talking about it was
really interesting is like there has
never been a drug free society,
nor would you want one.
You know,
it doesn't exist.
So this,
this idea is so stupid that it's been
hammered into us this impossible ideal.
And it's,
it's because of the ability to
communicate.
It's ironic that,
you know,
the,
the ability to communicate through mass
amounts of people is so recent within
the last few hundred years,
thousand years,
whatever it's been that we,
the impact of these things,
although in our incredibly small,
finite lives,
seems like forever is a comparatively
just a little tiny blip on the radar
where,
where we've had this sort of cultural
hiccup where we lost the script and the
Internet seems to be what's resetting
the,
the information.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why marijuana,
besides the financial reason,
my marijuana has gained so much steam.
The,
the,
just the sheer overwhelming avalanche of
facts,
the of desks,
the ld 50 rate of 1500 pounds in 15
minutes.
Like just the sheer absurdity of what it
takes to kill you.
And then the stats that come in.
I mean,
how many times can you see someone
posted with the numbers?
People die by cigarettes,
uh,
numbers.
People don't buy prescription drugs.
The numbers of people don't buy alcohol,
the number of people.
And you just start looking at that and
then marijuana gets to the bottom.
Zero.
Well,
what the fuck,
you know,
it's over and over and over and over
again.
It's resetting.
This is strange propaganda,
but to people that have been alive
through it,
it's indoctrination.
It's and how we've come to understand
the world,
but the message is penetrating now.
It is now with all that cultural baggage
that that is,
that marijuana is loaded down with.
Finally,
the real message is coming through when
people are exactly like you say
beginning to wake up to it and compared
to all the other recreational drugs that
we accept,
this one is benign and beneficial.
I've said that I think that in the
future when people look back on this age
where people were being arrested in
prison for marijuana,
they're going to look back at the same
way they used to look at at killing
witches.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's really that ridiculous.
It's just,
it's so.
It's such a a black mark on our,
our silly society and just an indication
of how disconnected we are.
This,
this concept of a drug free society,
as you say,
is totally absurd because you know
we're.
We're made of drugs.
In fact,
we are drugs and uh,
you know,
uh,
our brains run on neurotransmitters and
whether they're endogenously produced
and we know,
for example,
that dmt is an endogenous
neurotransmitter and that's a whole
fascinating area of neuroscience now,
potential functions for Dmt,
uh,
you know,
are being found.
We know it's been there for a long time.
We've known it's endogenous,
but it's not so clear what the hell it's
doing in there.
Now we're beginning to get some
indications that it really does have a
function,
for example,
in places that you wouldn't expect
modulating the immune system.
For example.
All this stuff is emerging so,
you know,
uh,
I mean by any measure,
these internal chemicals are drugs.
They just happened to be drugs that we
make ourselves.
We don't buy them from the local pot
dealer or whatever.
So,
you know,
so the perceptions are,
are changing.
I think.
Yeah.
Three,
I think,
um,
again,
I attribute the Internet and um,
some of the workload that uh,
rick strassman has done.
It's been pretty fascinating as well.
And the most recent work showing that
DMT is actually produced in the pineal
gland of of live rats,
which was always,
for whatever reason,
even though everyone knew dmt was a
endogenous neurotransmitter and that
human beings absolutely produced in the
liver and the lungs and different parts
of the body.
The pineal gland has always been
ultimately incredibly fascinating
because it literally is that third eye,
the seed of the soul,
and there was so much resistance to that
idea that this mystical chemical is
actually produced by the third eye.
And I saw online like all this battling
back and forth of,
well,
it's only anecdotal evidence that it's
produced by now.
There's actual physical evidence.
There's know it's there.
We knew it had to be there,
all the enzymes to make it all the
precursors to make it were there,
but nobody had actually nailed it down.
Now they've nailed it down.
So that's progress.
That's a step.
But that's the,
the,
the resistance to the idea was very
fascinating to me.
Like why,
why would anybody care whether or not it
was pretty.
I mean the body makes it for sure.
Like why is it such an issue that the
pineal gland makes it,
but it is.
It is because that sort of opens up the
door to eastern mysticism to all that
traditional religious art that showed
the glowing third eye and you know,
all these peaceful,
enlightened beings with a lit third
eyes,
like all of that is like,
oh well,
they probably knew something like,
oh,
there's something to it.
They did know a thing.
Well,
they knew quite a bit.
Right?
Because the other thing is the Egyptian
artwork that so clearly resembles the
pineal gland and the actual cross
section of the human brain and there's.
There's so much of that in ancient
civilizations,
in ancient cultures.
It just makes you really try to piece
together like,
when did we lose all this?
Like what have we figured that out?
When,
when did all that sort of slip away,
it gets lost.
I mean,
obviously it's not lost.
We're now rediscovering it.
It was just,
it was esoteric,
you know,
it was esoteric knowledge for a long
time.
Now it's becoming less esoteric.
More people are becoming aware of what
the ancients knew,
what the visionaries of the mystics
always knew.
This is no longer hidden knowledge,
you know,
it's becoming more accessible and that's
partly the effect of the Internet and
partly the effect of a lot of very smart
people obsessing over this,
you know,
and sharing what they're finding out.
So again,
this is a,
I think,
part of the general raising of
consciousness in this area that's going
on now.
Amber Lyon,
who's a,
she was a reporter for CNN and a sort of
lost their faith in mainstream news when
she did a piece on Bahrain and it got a
redacted and edited and turned into like
a tourist piece and she,
you know,
she left CNN.
It was this huge thing.
She was really like trying to figure out
what to do with their life.
And uh,
I,
I suggested psychedelic drugs.
So she goes down to Peru,
takes like,
just jumps on a plane,
like literally grabs what clothes she
had in her,
jumps on a plane,
goes to Peru,
take seven.
A long Iowasca trips completely changes
their life,
goes on a year round journey,
your long journey to discover various
psychedelic medicines and in different
indigenous cultures goes to Thailand and
does mushrooms,
goes to Mexico,
just does all that.
Now she's writing or making this website
called reset me.
She's dedicated her life to psychedelics
within one year,
one crazy transformative trip and it's
people like her and people like you and
people like you that are putting this
information out and starting this sort
of like undeniable tide is shifting,
is undeniable shifting,
right?
Right.
Psychedelics and neurotransmitters aside
because people expect something big when
they take these things and people are
rightly a little apprehensive.
I mean it will change your life if you
take these plants,
but if you want to have a transformative
experience with plants and you're leery
of psychedelics,
try going on a an all plant based diet
for a little while.
Change your intestinal bacteria and way
you'll.
You'll have this sense of levity,
lightness.
It will change the way you think about
yourself,
not as quickly as a psychedelic plant
experience and it takes discipline or
try a fast.
I mean,
there are ways to have these,
these transformative experiences without
drugs,
without plants,
but it's just
the only transformative experience that
I've ever experienced from dealing with
people that have gone in a completely
transforming their life in a completely
plant based diet is they can never shut
the fuck up about the fact that they're
on a plant based.
Well,
you have to,
you over the head with it.
It's a hard lifestyle to maintain.
Yeah.
Um,
and in,
in light of,
of the
new information that's been discovered
over the past decade or so about the
intelligence of plants,
about plants' ability to calculate their
ability to recognize,
um,
uh,
perhaps even a memory,
their,
their ability to recognize dangers,
their ability to adapt.
There's a consciousness in plants that
is undeniable and I think very
misunderstood or not understood.
That's not a word,
but we're,
we're ignorant to it.
And that's one of the problems that I
have with people that push the plant
based diet.
Like I don't think.
I think life eats life and I think it
always has.
And I think,
you know,
you can get to the very bottom of the
Karma chain where you're,
you know,
you're a fun guy and you're living off
of poop and you know,
basically things that things are thrown
away or you can be a tiger,
you know,
and they're all beautiful.
The whole system is crazy and beautiful.
And the only reason why we exist at all
is that a fucking star had a die.
You know what I mean?
The whole thing is death.
But we're so obsessed with this idea of
eating only plants or you know,
eating,
being on a plant based Diet connects you
more to nature.
I've become a hunter over the last year
and a half and I,
I couldn't disagree more.
One of the reasons being is that hunting
is a very psychedelic experience and
weird way that I never would have
believed.
Um,
the first time I ever went deer hunting
and shot a deer and then wound up eating
it.
There's a weird connection that you have
with nature and with that animal.
When you do that,
especially if you do it and what's
termed a fair chase environment,
you go out into the actual woods,
you deal with an animal,
most likely,
that animal right there,
it never even seen a human being before
I shot it.
And then we're eating it.
That deer had,
right?
They're not the alien,
the alien,
that motherfucker he's talking to you.
But I think that there's,
there's life in everything and there's
most likely some form of a consciousness
in all life.
And,
um,
and I think brains are overrated.
You know,
nervous systems are overrated in a
certain sense.
You could say,
well,
how could a plant be intelligent?
It's,
it doesn't have a nervous system.
It doesn't have a brain,
but it clearly displays intelligence.
And in fact,
speaking of that,
speaking of your hunting and experience,
you know,
the author Michael Pollan,
right?
Uh,
he,
he had a great essay and I think the New
Yorker recently about plants
intelligence,
that if you haven't read it,
it's worth reading.
But I also love his chapter in the
Omnivore's dilemma,
which is,
uh,
which is subtitled the natural history
of four meals.
And one of the meals is a meat meal
where he,
where he wants to create a meal,
but he wants to do it.
He wants to put himself in the shoes of
100 gatherer,
so he wants to gather all wild foods,
plant foods,
obviously mushrooms,
pine nuts and this sort of thing.
But he also wants to hunt down a bore,
I think it was,
and kill it and strip it,
skin it,
cut it up and eat it and have that
experience.
And I think that what you say is totally
legitimate if you're gonna eat meat,
it's important that people realize where
that an animal died so that you could
have that meal and native Americans,
indigenous people have always recognized
this because they are up against it.
So,
you know,
they'll always think the animal for what
their kid,
aiden.
And that's,
uh,
that's really important.
And that's something that we should try
to integrate into everything.
Why not thank the plants too.
Thank you.
Know,
thank everything we wouldn't be here if
we weren't sustained this web of life.
So why are we being so disrespectful to
it?
I mean,
I guess that's the crux of the question,
will we
can't really feel what we're doing to
this earth in and we,
we have this diffusion of responsibility
thing got me to the grocery store and
wrapped in plastic.
You have no notion where it actually
came from.
Yeah.
I've made a commitment this year to live
entirely off of a game.
Meat of wild game,
all wild to nothing that,
you know,
no pendant animals.
They just wind up shooting the hand that
I was telling you guys about before the
show smoking ham.
That's a pig.
I killed a on this ranch to hone ranch
and they actually have to have hunters
come in because these,
these are invasive species,
these wild pigs and they will destroy
everything.
They deer fawns,
they grounding a ground nesting birds.
They eat their eggs.
I mean they're,
they're unbelievably devastating to the
environments that they,
uh,
aren't naturally a part of.
Right?
So there's a role for us as stewards of
the environment,
these,
these wild boar,
sir,
unless you say they're devastating
ecosystems.
I don't know in California,
but Hawaii,
this is their biggest problem and it's
destroying ecosystems in Hawaii.
So there is a role for us to step in and
say,
well,
you know,
we're going to kind of exert some
control here and control that population
because they didn't originate in Hawaii.
They are invasive species,
as you say,
from your agents need for some
regulation.
Well,
there's an issue right now in San Jose,
San Jose,
they've started to make,
make their way into suburbs and they're
destroying people's lawns and uh,
you know,
they'll,
they'll have children.
Do you fucking shit.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
it,
it is a weird connection.
The connection that,
uh,
that we have to,
to,
to life itself and the,
our thoughts when we talk about native
Americans,
like almost immediately we think of the
spiritual connection that native
Americans had to the land,
the deep respect that they had for the
animals that they killed in the fact
that they would use every single piece
of that animal.
They'd use the hide to make the a roof
or close they would use Sydney,
you for,
for uh,
for strings,
for their bows and arrows.
The,
they literally used every part tooth,
bone,
nail flesh.
They ate them and they worship these
animals,
you know,
and it was,
it was a deep respect.
It was an inexorable part of the
relationship to nature itself.
Yeah.
I really hear you on this.
I grew up in the woods of Michigan mile
outside of a town of 150 people and my
uncle is a hunter and a taxidermist,
but hunting for him as a spiritual quest
and experience and you feel the pain of
the animal you kill and utilizing all
aspects of it.
I'm not,
I'm not opposed to eating meat by any
means.
I'm just saying that an Alpine plant
diet when when you do it properly can
transform consciousness.
It's a,
it's a strange thing,
but going on an all meat diet and eating
that conscious,
conscious eating can change conscious,
conscious,
subconscious everything,
right?
Every design of institutions,
of,
of the Internet,
of our experiences.
Yeah.
Other people,
when you were talking about earlier
about brains being overrated,
one of the things that I've really,
it's been inescapable for me over the
last few years or so is this idea that
we're the caterpillars that are giving
birth to the moth and that our whole
screwy system and our whole,
you know,
are issues with ego problems and
materialism might be because we're just
sort of a transitionary stage to this
symbiotic relationship that we have with
technology and then we're going to give
birth.
There's some artificial thing that
doesn't carry the burdens of natural
selection that doesn't carry the burdens
of primitive instincts,
the needs or survive all these animal
reward systems that were built into us
from the time that we were monkeys.
Perhaps it doesn't sound like a very
nice existence.
Sound like a nice existence,
but I'm not sure about that.
This is why bounce it around because I
don't know.
I don't know if it's better.
I mean the idea is that,
well,
if I'm not a person,
well I'm fucked.
But is that the ego hanging onto that?
I mean,
is it is some sort of hyper intelligent
artificial life that's capable of living
completely,
uh,
completely self sustaining existence
where you're totally solar powered all
garbage or any waste product whatsoever.
It's factored immediately into the
equation instead of put off like nuclear
waste where they just dig a fucking hole
and Oh,
we'll figure that out later.
That's madness.
To me,
the nuclear waste issue is one of the
most maddening and insane issues ever
where they take these things,
they build holes and then they put it in
there and then they seal it up.
Like,
what do you look a little kid like,
are you fucking crazy?
That's like what a little kid would do
when they have to clean their room.
They lift up the carpet,
they sweep it under the,
they put the carpet down.
It's a childish way of approaching an
issue.
Instead of having a completely holistic
approach to this,
this thing like,
okay,
are we going to build this stuff?
If we are going to build this stuff,
what are we going to do about the toxic
waste?
Okay,
well let's factor that in before we move
forward.
And then spend an extra few decades
trying to figure out what to do with
that shit and then maybe come up with a
solution before you ever moved forward.
But we don't do that.
We have this weird thing that we just
sort of put it off and we child
companies have quarterly
reporting requirements.
If we just changed the financial
reporting structure just one year,
a five year instead of this short term
thinking,
well solar panels are cheaper.
At least this is what has to be factored
into corporate planning,
as you say,
because in the operations have gotten a
free ride for too long because they'd
never pay the environmental consequences
of what they do,
you know?
And we have to change that where they
have to be held accountable and
responsible for the environmental
impact.
It's not just that you pay $200 for an
iphone,
you know,
you pay $200 for an iphone,
but it cost $2,000
to deal with the environmental impact of
the toxic waste.
That economic equation has got to
change.
And that's one of the biggest challenges
because it's a huge.
It's a huge challenge to capitalism.
It's,
it's laying down the gauntlet and say,
look guys,
okay,
you can make money,
but let's make,
let's look at the bottom line in the
realistic way and you're making all this
profit,
but what are you costing the taxpayers
and the rest of society for your profit
making activities?
How about a little payback here?
You know,
how about,
you know,
some fun,
some way to compensate for the damage
that,
that corporations do.
And that's,
that's the,
that's the biggest threat that I can see
right now.
The corporations want to own everything.
They want to corporatize everything.
And nature is just another commodity as
they see it to be owned and exploited.
And uh,
that's the perception that's got to
change.
And maybe one way to do it this to,
you know,
I,
I think speaking of hearts and minds,
I think if you can get in there are
ethical capitalists out there,
you know,
chances are they're partly ethical
because they took psychedelics at some
point.
I mean,
Steve Jobs and people like that,
you know,
and um,
we could name others.
So,
you know,
psychedelics are teaching tools to help
people kind of understand their,
their place,
their responsibilities,
and uh,
uh,
you know,
we have to,
again,
that's part of this.
It's not that we can't innovate,
we just have to be realistic about the
impact that our actions are having.
We also have this issue with
incorporations having survival instincts
and corporations.
This unlimited growth paradigm.
This is impossible,
right?
Like what we're talking about with like
laptops that.
Can we just stop right here?
No,
we can't.
It's impossible.
And we also can't stop as far as profit.
Well,
we made this much this quarter and this
quarter we showed a 25 percent growth.
Excellent.
Let's keep moving on by 2075,
we should have all the money in the
world.
I mean,
that's really what every corporation.
And isn't this
what's happening?
Yes it is.
It's madness,
right?
Got,
what is it?
Ninety five percent of the wealth
concentrated in the one percent and the
rest of us are,
you know,
the rest of us is,
it's quickly evolving into a third world
situation and,
and that,
that is economic slavery in a sense.
I mean people do what they have to do
because they don't have a choice.
Their,
you know,
their economic activity,
they're priorities are dictated by
corporations.
This idea that profit is the only thing
that a corporation should be concerned
with.
We've got to evolve beyond that.
Sustainability is more important.
Uh,
helping people's lives be better as more
important than profits.
I mean sure profits,
but that should be down several notches
I think,
on the,
on the totem pole in terms of what they
identify as
important.
I think it should be like food.
I think profit should be like food in
that you can't eat poison and that if
you're eating something and look,
we have all these calories.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's fucking killing you,
right?
You understand that you can't eat this.
This is bad for you.
Like don't like this,
but it's got a thousand calories,
you know,
I need calories to where,
no,
you don't need those calories.
That's poison.
And,
and essentially the idea of profit is
profit overall and profit over humanity.
You know,
the idea of financial,
financial gain over human suffering like
that somehow or another it balances out
is just like eating poison.
I mean,
it really is.
There should be no profit at all when
this human suffering.
It should be one of those things with.
It's factored in,
oh we can't eat this.
It's poisoned for humanity,
right?
Yeah.
The corporation in the u s if it does
not maximize profit,
can be sued by its shareholders.
That's the law.
They have a legal responsibility to
maximize profit.
That's so crazy.
And so we have to change the laws that
shareholders
until the shareholders start demanding
that they actually act responsibly.
So that's.
I don't know how that works,
but you know,
if the shareholders achieve a higher
level of consciousness,
maybe they can influence the way the
corporate.
It was a NASA funded study looking at
collapse of civilizations and one of the
major factors is the discrepancy in
wealth that the wealthy people are using
up the resources and they're insulated
from the effects and then it gets to a
point where the people making decisions
haven't been thinking about the the the
consequences and the alternatives and
it's.
It's something's gotta change.
Yeah,
that's a.
That was a fascinating and very
terrifying report because this is not
someone with any financial interest in
relaying this message is not something
that someone that's selling a solution,
they're just looking at all the data and
go and look.
If you just follow these trends,
this is where it goes.
No,
there's no,
no indication whatsoever that it's going
to slow down.
This is,
this is where we're going.
We have to figure this out before we hit
this wall.
[inaudible],
when I was an Undergrad,
I was in business school until I took
five grams of siliciden mushrooms.
Today I grew in my dormitory closet at
the urging of Terence Mckenna's book.
See old generic method under buying
civilization.
One chart at a time of civilization.
Radical,
but I realized that I was fighting a
losing battle if I wasn't speaking the
same language of making some profit of
appealing to people's business
interests.
I.
It was a long process.
I wanted to get out of this culture and
ended up in China teaching English and
I've spent most of the last 10 years in
China.
I'm like a third Chinese now basically,
and I became comfortable analyzing the
situation I was in meeting people on
their level because I can't.
One thing being in China teaches you is
to be constructive with people to come
at an issue from how they're thinking
about it.
So I began that.
Why is that people don't want to lose
face,
so it's a,
it's a top down culture so you
understand the priorities of a leader
and they have some enlightened
interests.
They have their self interests as well,
and you appeal to their better image of
themselves.
What's possible a win win situation
where,
so I think of myself now as a kind of
economic therapist.
I talked to corporations,
I talked to ngos,
the campaigning organizations,
and I try to help people find a balance.
What is,
what are the win win situation,
so the last six years I've been working
with the global sustainability standards
like the forest stewardship council and
the Marine Stewardship Council and the
ESC is modeled on these organizations
that you talk with enough stakeholders
and you build consensus through dialogue
and you have a transparent process that
appeals to companies that appeals to
regulators,
so take Mcdonald's for example,
they realized that they were catching
too much fish from the ocean and it
wasn't sustainable,
so they now all Mcdonald's fish
sandwiches are marine stewardship
council certified,
which means they can sell fish
sandwiches into eternity as long as the
oceans are a viable for life.
Or Kimberly Clark was cutting down the
rain forests and cutting down the
arboreal forest in Canada.
Now all of their paper products are
going to be FSC certified.
An FSC certifies 15 percent of the
standing forest of the world,
which means that people have a fair
share.
This worship reserves,
stewardship I think is really important.
It's an important word.
Gotten to be reintroduced
into corporate thinking in corporate
planning as opposed to profits.
I mean,
we all have a stake in survival,
not everybody has a stake in profits to
the shareholders have a stake in
profits,
but there's no profits if we don't
survive,
if this whole shooting match collapses.
So the concept of stewardship and I
think that is,
is really important to get that message
out and that's what people like Josh or
trying to do.
And I think psychedelics have a role to
play absolutely.
In educating,
you know,
uh,
I mean,
it's interesting the,
you know,
we can't,
it's going to be awhile.
I think before Iowasca gets integrated
in this country in a way,
for example,
in therapy and in biomedicine,
it's not gonna happen,
but what you do see happening are the
centers that are growing up and right
now it's in South America and Josh and
Ethno Botanical Stewardship Council are
trying to develop standards for these
organizations so that,
you know,
they're committed to a certain ethical,
a set of standards,
safety and quality of their,
of their brew and so on.
But I can envision a time not too far in
the future where if a person,
you know,
you can go to South America and if you
have issues,
if you have sickness,
addiction or whatever,
you could get treatment,
but even more importantly,
you can just get an education,
you can just get a,
you can,
you can go there for purposes of
spiritual discovery and self discovery
and all that.
Once you have that infrastructure,
which is growing,
then it partly becomes,
you know,
we need to get people in positions of
power,
corporate ceos,
other government leaders and so on,
to go and have these experience.
That's the big one,
right?
We've,
yeah,
I mean you can't hold them in a headlock
and force them to drink IOWASCA.
Although I'd like to
a catalyst for creativity.
Take your marketing team to South
America and have a ceremony together,
rebrand your company.
Exactly.
Increase your profits in the process and
the benefits to people.
That's people.
That's where the economic,
that's where the model comes in.
People have a negative reaction to that.
And I know this personally firsthand
because,
uh,
I have a business on it,
on a.com
is a company we sell exercise equipment
and supplements and healthy foods.
And one of the ways that on it was
created was a,
my partner Aubrey and I talking about it
and Aubrey going to South America,
doing Iowasca and then having these
visions about his business.
And when you talked about that,
he was met with so much criticism.
So many people were like,
ah,
you're down there doing Iowasca thinking
about your business.
Oh,
that's so gross.
that's so based.
That's so egocentric.
That,
so the anti,
you know,
the,
the message of the plant.
But it's creativity and creativity.
It manifests itself in a million
different ways.
And it is the idea of business equals
evil really has to get,
we have to get past that because we all
exchange,
you know,
it's not evil.
If some guy could fix your car,
If someone can fix your,
your,
uh,
your refrigerator so you can store food.
All those things are businesses
not evil.
If you buy fair trade,
coffee promotes biodiversity and farmers
can send their kids to school,
go to hell.
So it is.
It's when,
when it's possible to develop these
economic models.
So I totally disagree with your,
your partners,
critics.
Your partner is exactly right on and
it's okay.
He,
with his background,
I assume it's a,
he goes to South America and he already
has the mindset,
right?
Then Iowasca is a way to sort of flesh
out the vision if you were.
I mean,
he,
he went there to learn something and boy
to Dillard's someplace.
Clearly he went through a bunch of other
things about his life will,
you've got to get the personal shit,
clear family history,
open up that bullshit folder,
get hit over the head.
None of us here has done that
completely.
I mean at some point the process.
Yeah,
no,
no doubt about it.
You know,
um,
uh,
I got a tank session scheduled for
tonight on some little workout.
Um,
the,
uh,
the word ethical company or the
expression ethical company I think is a,
is a big one.
And I think that this,
this idea of the psychedelic experience
for those who haven't experienced it or
for those who,
oh,
I dropped acid in college,
but I'm past that now.
I've got a 401k in a mortgage and
college bills for my kids and I have a
lot of.
Yeah.
But that's an excuse for not wanting to
confront it.
That's just,
that's just self self delusion.
Really.
Nobody's ever passed.
No.
No one ever,
ever.
If you're a human being and you have,
you're a constant sort of soup of
chemicals,
neurotransmitters,
adrenaline,
hormones,
all these different things are going on
and you're trying to maintain balances
and keep everything aligned and then
keep the pattern of thought in a good
place.
So that maintains everything as well.
I think that to these people that are
perpetrating a lot of the issues that we
have,
whether it's the head of bp or you know,
it takes some guy wants to frack and
say,
before you do that,
do this first.
And then let's talk,
you know,
like confronted with your own mortality
should almost be mandatory.
I mean,
you should show that you went before.
You start fracking,
you should show that you have a degree
that you understand the actual physical
process of removing these chemicals.
You should understand,
you know,
whatever energy extraction degrees you
have to have in whatever science is that
pertain to that,
but you should also have psychedelic
trips under your belt.
Like you'd say,
well,
you know,
here,
uh,
I seen your documentation.
You've gone through your five grams and
what did you get out of that?
You know what I mean?
Like it should be one of those things
where it's reviewed,
like,
okay,
you haven't,
what you've gotten off your list before
you proceed.
It shouldn't be like a presidential
council for psychological fitness.
And they,
they sit you down,
they go,
you don't have any psychedelic
experiences on your resume.
Ready the brain now?
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Opening up the fucking company that digs
holes in the ground and you don't have
any psychedelic experiences.
That's a recipe for disaster.
So you're missing a key component.
You're,
you're missing this connection to the
mother Earth via some unfathomable bowl
experience that literally is impossible
to describe [inaudible].
So you're missing that part.
So go get that and then come back.
Then we'll talk about your business.
Yes.
Are People in the Department of Defense
or the veterans affairs that are dealing
with all these soldiers with PTSD?
Another important aspect of the
symposia.
Conferences,
a new organization called Vet Veterans
for NPO genic therapy.
Oh,
that's great.
Founders participated in the maps ptsd
study with MDA and they came away
feeling so much better and they want to
open this up to other veterans and
others suffering from Ptsd.
So a portion of the proceeds from the
[inaudible] conference in the live,
the online live participation will.
We'll go to this organization and to the
ESC.
That's spectacular.
I'm a huge,
huge fan of maps.
I've done Rick Doblin on the podcast
before.
It was just a fantastic guy and he,
uh,
they just tweeted me something and I
retweeted it about,
uh,
they did a new study on autism,
adult autism Mtma at assisted therapy
for social anxiety and autistic adults
and some amazing,
amazing dinner.
Charlie Grove working.
Was he working on that?
He's Charlie Grove who's a at Ucla.
He's one of our heffter superstars,
if you will know his name so we can get
them on the poster or ob Charles Grope.
He's at Harbor Ucla.
He's done a.
he's done a silicide.
Been end of life study.
He's a member of the heffter board.
I may as well plug heffter here where
the sort of a small organization that
nobody knows about.
Heffter.org.
A cow.
No,
no.
F E,
h e f,
F,
t,
e r after,
but after it's a nonprofit and basically
we're committed to clinical development
and clinical protocols with a,
with a psychedelic,
some of kind of staked out.
Silicide been in some ways the same way
that Mtma is.
Map says things.
Silicide business our thing.
And we've got several really interesting
protocols.
FDA approved clinical studies right now
for end of life,
a existential anxiety at the end of
life,
uh,
for exploring actually what you might
call experimental mysticism because a
psilocybin can reliably induce mystical
states.
Roland griffiths work at Johns Hopkins
has shown this,
so it's an actual tool for the first
time we're actually able to approach
transcendent states of mind in a
controlled clinical setting.
We can reliably,
uh,
induce these states and then study
what's the brain doing when,
when you're in a state of siliciden
induced mysticism.
Well,
that's doing a lot of things similar to
the state of a mystical experience when
you're on the nat.
Sure.
Whatever.
I'm not sure that even.
But anyway,
heffter.org,
most of the leading researchers in
psychedelic science right now are either
on our board are being funded by heffter
and so we have funding and we're
focusing on suicide,
but then we work closely with maps,
but maps gets all the attention,
which is fine.
They are doing beautiful work,
but we're also doing effective
important.
Well,
we'll,
we'll certainly get some people to you.
I'm heffter h e f f t e r.org.org
named after Arthur heffter actually
who's the.
He was a 19th century scientist,
the first person to isolate masculine in
a pure form from pod and demonstrate
that it was the main ingredient of,
of payoti based on self experiments.
So he was kind of exemplifies what we
like to identify with,
you know,
good science driven by curiosity and
ethics and uh,
yeah,
it's a good organization.
The silicide been connection to
dimethyltryptamine dimethyltryptamine
being an endogenous chemical,
a neurotransmitter,
and psilocybin being very close,
very close.
What is the exact,
like what's the chemical?
Was the.
Okay,
very simple.
Dimethyltryptamine is simply
dimethyltryptamine a silicon,
which is the active principle of
psilocybin.
PSILOCYBIN is converted to allison in
the body.
So it's what pharmacologists call a pro
drug.
It's converted by a very simple chemical
reaction to silverson.
That's the one that actually interacts
with the receptors.
So silicon is chemically four hydroxy
dimethyltryptamine.
So it differs with one trivial
substitution on the Indole ring.
That oxygen,
that alcohol group at the top of the
Indole ring is what makes it sill a
sudden.
And not DMT,
but it makes all the difference
pharmacologically because silicon is
orally active and it doesn't require an
Mao inhibitor.
And,
and DMT does,
if,
if you need,
that's the Iowasca secret,
you know,
dmt plus Mao inhibitor makes the orally
active preparation by itself.
DMT is not orally active,
so you have to take it perennially by
smoking it or indigenous people make
snuff out of it and so on.
And they get,
get around that whole a detoxification
mechanism.
Your gut is full of his full of Mao
monetary amine oxidase and the reason
it's full of monitoring the next day.
So it's a,
it's a consequences of our evolution as
omnivores because plants are full of,
uh,
means,
most of them are toxic and you don't
want those.
You've got the,
so you have the detoxification
mechanism,
but they had also works for dmt.
And for that matter,
we can't be dining on dmt containing
plants all the time and wandering
around.
I mean,
you do need to be able to function in
the world.
Um,
your,
your brother had a fascinating idea
about,
um,
the,
the idea of Panspermia in relationship
to a suicide and suicide and being the,
how did you,
what is the exact nomenclature again for
a high four hydroxy four hydroxy trip
dimethyltryptamine yeah,
that silicide been,
I don't want to get bogged down in
chemistry,
but Phil Psilocybin for the chemists
among you,
it's got a phosphoryl group and that
phosphoryl group is cleaved off and that
yields Cilla sin.
Sin.
Sin Is four hydroxy die methyl trip to
me.
What is silicide been and silicide
business for phosphoryl dimethyl methyl
trip to me.
So it's got that phosphoryl group that
makes it stable,
right?
So that's the form it's stored in the
mushroom and it can be quite stable for
a long time.
Soon as you convert it to Siliciden,
it's very unstable and it's a femoral,
which is one reason why it's so easily
metabolized by human metabolism.
It's very compatible with human
metabolism,
which is a reason why it's so,
you know,
it's appropriate.
You can give it to people who are quite
ill,
you know,
in terminal states and so on,
and they can tolerate it's,
it's not a,
it goes through a human organism like
ice water.
It's very easily handled.
Uh,
no,
but,
uh,
we don't,
we don't want to get to know down the
road.
Don't know.
It's,
it's absolutely fascinating.
But yeah,
the,
uh,
the idea
that your brother was promoting was that
this may have come from another planet
and that what you might be eating when
you're eating mushrooms is you're eating
some sort of an intelligence,
which is the weirdest thing about
mushrooms is that it feels like they're
talking to you.
We do have that impression.
This I thou dynamic that's set up and
the content,
which I guess not everybody has this,
you know,
this,
this feeling of this science fictiony
she cast to the experience,
but many people do and they,
they're not all terence Mckenna fans.
I mean,
if you,
if you follow the terence mckenna recipe
and eat five grams and the absolute
darkness,
you'll be utterly convinced that they've
landed there here.
And whether that's just an impression or
whether it's,
uh,
you know,
some,
again,
I think this is possibly something,
you know,
built into the structure of our nervous
system,
you know,
and it may be,
I mean,
we've always had this,
this fascination with,
with space,
with,
you know,
with the external,
uh,
you know,
with the,
the,
this sort of longing to maybe return to
space.
Maybe that's where we came from.
I don't know,
you know,
but certainly in,
in this,
in this a evolutionary process of
cognition,
you know,
which we credit the plants for.
If we want to buy into that idea,
we credit the plants for bringing about
cognition.
The ability to wonder,
the ability to speculate.
Well,
we can't wonder if very much,
if you're looking down at the ground all
the time,
you got to look up when you look up,
you,
oh,
you know,
there's this whole universe out here.
And uh,
what's our connection to that?
You know,
we,
we've always had this intuition that
there is a connection.
I mean,
I,
uh,
don't go so far as to say,
you know,
people ridiculed the idea that mushrooms
might've come from outer space and so
on,
and I'm a surface,
it seems like a ridiculous idea,
but you look a little deeper and maybe
not so much,
you know,
it's certainly possible that spores are
one of the hardest substances in nature
and they can survive.
They can survive in a vacuum and
radiation dense environments and they're
not effective.
Did the other thing that your brother
had mentioned was that it was so
different than other life forms on earth
because of its chemical makeup that he
thought that the four hydroxy or for,
for phosphoryl yeah,
the four hydroxy form
floral,
a biosynthetic pathway is really only
found in this group of mushrooms,
you know,
actually unrelated species.
Yeah.
He wasn't,
he wasn't a biochemist.
I don't know if I agree with that.
I mean mushrooms are so clearly a part
of a,
you know,
earthly evolution that you can't really
say that they stand outside of it to.
I mean,
we know that's true.
I think if you want to make that
hypothesis,
you have to go further back and you have
to say,
well,
you know,
maybe a super civilization see did our
ecology at some point,
not with the genes to make a silly one,
but the genes to make tryptofan and now
tryptofan all these silicon and
Serotonin and all these tryptamines come
from tryptofan.
And tryptofan is one of those 20 amino
acids that make up proteins.
So tryptofan is universally found in all
organisms.
It's,
you know,
it's an essential,
a molecule of life,
right?
It's found in everything.
But to trivial steps away from tryptofan
too.
Trivial enzymatic modifications away
from tryptofan.
You've got DMT.
You know,
you remove the carboxyl group,
you stick a couple of methyl groups on
Tryptophan and there you are.
You've got DMT.
And I've often thought,
wow,
maybe this is a sort of sub text,
sub message of nature saying just around
the corner,
just around the corner from Tryptofan
is,
uh,
this,
this compound that opens the door to
other dimensions,
pay attention monkeys.
Fascinating that trip,
defend converts to eventually converge
to Serotonin.
That is
Serotonin is just another trip to me.
Uh,
in fact,
chemically Serotonin is five hydroxy
tryptamine.
Siliciden is four hydroxy die methyl
trip to me.
Blue photo name,
another one of these hallucinogens is
five hydroxy methyl trip to me.
So they're all,
you know,
very close to each other.
You see the diagrams,
I'll hail.
There you are,
there you go.
Right?
So you can see how,
how it works,
the idea that mushrooms come from outer
space,
it seems ridiculous to some folks,
but the reality is we were made out of
stars that everything comes from outer
space and I think that as we get further
along in our understanding of the
universe,
I think we're going to realize that
everything is kind of fractal and there
really is no separation between this
planet and other planets of the whole
thing is just one big soup.
Right,
right,
exactly.
And,
you know,
any,
um,
prebiotic environment,
I mean,
we don't know that much about exactly
how life evolved,
but we know that in certain situations
you've got to a buildup of organic
compounds and,
uh,
under the right,
it just seems to be a property of
matter.
You know,
Adam's molecules fall together in such a
way that before you know it,
you've got living systems.
You've brought this up twice and I can't
ignore it because he brought it up in
the last podcast as well.
You,
you are fascinated by the idea of life
being seated here by some intelligent
force.
Uh,
Amber Lyon,
who,
uh,
I discussed earlier,
she had a vision of that actually
happening on Iowasca and many other
people have as well.
Do you think that that's something that
is,
is a real possibility?
Yes,
I do.
Wow,
that's a heavy one.
When you bring that one up,
you get thrown into that certain
category right away.
Oh,
Dennis Mckenna.
It's fucking gotta.
Read my book.
We actually in my book,
I mean it was.
Which one?
My book.
Oh,
the latest one.
The Old Lady.
Latest one.
I wrote the Brotherhood of the screaming
abyss.
Oh,
that's the one you promoted last time
you were on here,
which is excellent.
Which for that,
that was really good.
If you haven't bought it,
please folks go by.
It really gave her that.
You really gave it a boost.
But I actually talk about that.
Talk about this at some length about
this idea.
Could this really be,
and I'm trying to,
uh,
you know,
discuss it from the standpoint of a
critic of the idea.
Say,
well,
that's totally ridiculous,
you know,
how could that be?
And they just dismiss it.
I tried to go a little deeper intuitive.
Say,
well,
wait a minute,
let's step back from this a little bit.
And if you think about our existential
situation,
how unlikely it is that we are even here
that consciousness exists,
that this civilization exists.
I mean in,
in,
in the,
from the standpoint of the improbables,
we're living in a very improbable
situation.
You know,
if we should,
you know,
I don't think this is going on.
I think that life is probably a
widespread in the universe,
but I think intelligence is rare and the
fact that we find ourselves in that
existential situation,
you know,
maybe we need to look,
take another look at this and say,
well,
maybe this is not such a crazy idea.
You know,
that,
I mean,
I do think that intelligence,
uh,
you know,
is,
we're not the only ones.
And I think,
you know,
and,
uh,
I don't know if I generated into
incoherence here,
but I think that intelligence can have
an influence on the evolution of even
the universe.
You know,
it's a force in the universe.
And I think that mind is probably,
uh,
you know,
as primary,
uh,
feature of reality as,
as the quantum foam.
I mean,
it may not,
it may not even be separate from it,
you know.
So it's okay to say we don't know.
And,
and,
you know,
one
of the problems with science is,
uh,
it,
it tends to be arrogant to,
tends to assume that it knows a lot more
than it knows.
And we actually have a,
we have a very detailed understanding
scientifically,
of very small pieces of reality,
you know,
and so there's a tendency to say,
well,
we've got it all figured out.
No,
you haven't got it figured out.
You haven't got even a 10th of it
figured out,
which is another useful a message that
Iowasca and other entheogens,
other psychedelics a reminded us of,
you know,
I mean,
Iowaska never fails to remind me and a
lot of people remember you don't,
Oh shit,
you know,
you don't know shit,
so get off your high horse and be a
little more humble and be open to
learning.
It's all right in front of us.
If we go back and look at what we know
about human history and what they knew
and how we laugh at what they knew,
then we will go back to the time when
they thought the world was flat,
back to the time where,
you know,
they were killing Bruno because he
thought that the universe was infinite
back to.
I mean,
there's all these different things that
people like how to consensus.
Um,
there were absolutely incorrect that we
go back then we were foolish.
That was a blink of an eye ego,
right?
So the message is
be aware of what everybody knows.
Beware of cultural consensus,
because chances are in 100 years what we
thought we knew,
we'll just be seen in that light.
I mean,
we were so stupid back then.
Yeah,
that's also one of those things too,
when you're discussing aliens be
discussing the possibility of a,
an alien life form.
We want to think it's preposterous,
but we're preposterous if we,
if we didn't exist,
oh my God,
the most ridiculous thing ever right
behind me,
dead people that were locked in a cage
and I honored them.
This photos behind me of Jimmy Hendrix
and the Elvis actually apparently wasn't
really a,
a,
a mugshot.
He was just a law enforcement not
wanting to get his picture,
which is even more ridiculous.
He loved the fact that people got locked
into cages so much.
He wanted to get a fake picture of him
locked in a cage is most likely,
was high as fuck on pills,
you know?
And he went to the Nixon to be a drug
and.
Exactly.
And then this woman,
Rosa parks,
she got arrested because she had too
much melanin in our skin to sit in a
certain spot on a moving piece of
transportation.
And then she was celebrated as a hero.
I mean,
we're fucking crazy.
Right?
So totally why?
Wow.
Just the fact that we exist at all.
Why would we deny the idea that
something else far more advanced than us
exists somewhere else?
No,
no different than us looking at,
you know,
when we find primates using tools and
evidence of using tools without any
human.
Like they just figured it out how to do
it on their own to get inside of and
hills and things like that.
We're fascinated by amazing.
Look what we've discovered.
Jesus Christ.
It's easy.
Shit,
you know,
like compare us to something else.
They would probably look at us the same
way.
Look at these dummies.
They're,
they're worshiping people that were
locked in cages.
Right.
You're a hero because you're sitting in
a different spot.
That's the thing.
We're.
Yeah.
We're observing experiment of some sort.
And whether,
you know,
we're,
some civilization,
some super civilization as genetically
engineered this whole ecosystem and
create a trip to fan and see did it into
the ecosystem,
knowing that over the course of
evolutionary time it was going to
develop things like siliciden and
Serotonin.
It's almost as though the civilization,
this hypothetical civilization wanted
somebody to talk to and in order to do
that it had to invent as primates,
you know,
and it had to get us talking first to
our plants and maybe eventually we'll
get a chance to talk to them,
whoever they are,
you know,
or maybe they're already here.
I mean,
there are a lot of people say they're
already here,
you know,
and I,
yeah,
I don't.
Who knows,
the other problem is there's so many
people that are full of shit.
Well that is the area where flakiness is
flourishes hugely.
I had this Saifai show,
um,
and we stopped doing it for and they
wanted to keep doing it.
But I didn't want to do it anymore
because I got tired of talking to liars.
I couldn't handle it anymore.
We interviewed bigfoot Pete Boone Ufo
people and some of them are well
intentioned folks,
but there was a lot of liars.
There was a lot of people that were
just.
There was a psychological issue and I
can clearly see it because when you have
a podcast with someone and he sit down
with someone for three hours,
you can bullshit someone for a seven
minute interview on a news show,
but you can't bullshit someone for three
hours after three hours.
Weird things start to show up like weird
patterns or will you just can't keep
the.
Can't keep the rhythm up so to speak.
Especially if you could do multiple
podcasts like,
oh,
crack you.
After two or three,
I'll find you.
You might be very clever,
but after two or three little things get
exposed and you're like,
hm,
we reveal the basis to keep the rhythm
going.
You know,
it's just after a while if you're full
of Shit,
you're full of shit.
Also to yourself,
and that's something that I've found is
that people that are constantly
deceptive,
there are also internally deceptive and
that that manifests itself in weird
things that they say that they don't
even realize.
They're bizarre because they,
they're also easier to trick themselves
I think because I think they lose their
ability to really,
uh,
to,
to see things objective,
falsifiable facts,
things that you can prove that that's or
not
the scientific method is important.
And all of this theoretical conversation
is nice about whether we had,
we have the imprints of other
civilizations in our,
our ecosystem.
But the fact is we have an ecosystem and
we have maybe we delude ourselves that
we have some control over its evolution
or a stewardship of it,
but we certainly have this opportunity
to,
to either destroy the planet or,
or preserve it
well.
We certainly have an effect and we're
certainly conscious in some way,
shape or form of that effect.
And when you extrapolate that to a
$100,000
million years from now,
if the civilization or something similar
survives,
well you got to think that it's going to
be something like an alien invasion that
we,
we really will be like that thing that
wants to see the universe if we
recognize,
especially if you're being,
if you're an intelligent being and you
recognize that a star is a out we did,
a star is only good to support life for
another billion years.
That's not a lot of time.
If you really stop and think about how
long time has existed on earth and if
you were an intelligent species that
lived 100 million years from now and
you're like,
hey,
you know,
we only have nine more of these to go.
We have nine more of these 100 million
cycles and then we're fucked.
Then the Sun Burns out and there's no
life here.
We gotta get moving.
You know,
we stuck here.
Yeah,
that's very interesting.
I've often thought that these
cosmological models,
I think we got more than a billion
years.
The cosmological models say 10 to a
hundred billion years,
maybe a trillion years
with the sun,
I think.
Hold the sun.
Yeah,
the sun doesn't have our planet.
It's a support line.
It's got maybe 4 billion years.
But if we haven't figured out how to get
out by that time,
we're not paying attention,
you know,
but getting these costumes or Gideon,
exactly.
Or Gideon,
that's a very important point that,
you know,
I mean,
this,
uh,
I've been told on psychedelics many
times the only way out is to go in,
but,
but this,
you know,
these cosmological models,
if you look at them,
which are kind of dreary and depressing
when you think about it,
you know,
it's just now the current model is just
endless expansion and not only expansion
but accelerated expansion.
You're talking about the heat death of
the universe and you know,
not very much interested in is going to
happen.
But the key factor that these models do
not a do not integrate into their
planning his mind and consciousness,
you know.
And that makes all the difference that,
you know,
if you look far enough ahead,
that's gonna affect the way the cosmos.
He falls and uh,
uh,
you know,
and they don't take that into account
and it's impossible to really know what
the effects of it is.
But I don't buy the fact that it's all
going.
It just kind of Peter out.
And finally the last flicker is going to
go out and it's just darkness and cold.
I don't by that I mean surely there's
gotta be more to it than that.
Well,
the trip might be what we're missing.
Our emr trip may be.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean if you look at quantum models and
we know there's know three dimensions of
space and one of time,
but then there's the,
what is it,
the six or eight other dimensions that
are all folded in and you don't see
that,
but what's in there,
what's it?
But that's the feeling that you get on
dimethyltryptamine is that you've
entered into a new area,
a new space,
and that space is somehow or another
inhabited with something that's
communicating in some nonverbal forum
that reaches you as intent.
It reaches you like content and that
that might be where consciousness is
headed.
Once we free ourselves from this sort of
carbon based shell that we're,
we're,
we're clinging to that,
we might figure that out.
That like,
oh,
we're,
we're at a rest stop.
We didn't realize that we could drive
just a couple miles down the road and
there's the fucking yellowstone national
park.
Like,
we got that,
the rest stop.
We thought that that's where we were
eating shitty food and breathing trucker
farts and we saw there was,
oh my God,
we just had to just figure it out.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't dismiss that possibility.
I mean this,
this I vow relationship and that we say
that again,
I vow.
I vow this thing that mushrooms,
other psychedelics for their specialty
mushrooms seep to set up this dialogue
situation.
You know,
when you're getting this information,
but it's very hard to evaluate whether
it's,
whether it's bullshit or whether there's
something to it.
My,
my brother used to play games with the
mushrooms.
You know,
what he would take them at these high
doses alone and say,
well,
how do I know that?
What you're telling me is real,
tell me something I cannot possibly
know.
You know?
And they would never,
they would never cough it up because it
was like,
you know.
But it was like,
all right,
I want the blueprints to the star ship
now download the blueprints.
Now I don't believe that you're,
you are what you say you are.
And they're very invasive.
You know,
they'd never give you that kind of
thing.
But they.
So,
you know,
I don't know.
I have this thought on,
for people who've heard this podcast,
unfortunately,
I have to repeat myself.
I have this idea that we have this,
uh,
this dismissal of psychedelic
experience,
uh,
as hallucination and hallucination being
frivolous.
And my thought is that if you absorb
some sort of a psychedelic compound and
have this intense moment where you do
pass into another dimension and you,
you meet with pure love and the,
the,
the very wiring of the universe is
exposed to you and you get to see the
fractal nature of reality and some
incredibly profound for them.
And that is what you're actually
experiencing.
Or if it's just your imagination and you
go there and it's all in your mind,
but you have the exact same experience,
it's still the same,
like this idea that everything that's
real has to be.
You have to be able to take a tape
measure and touch it,
that you have to be able to put it on a
scale that you have to be able to
quantify the ingredients.
Oh well it's made out of aluminum and
this is glass and you know,
the keyboard is plastic that,
that.
Now I know a laptop's real.
No,
but I'm here to tell you it's all
hallucination,
right?
Right.
I mean,
we dwell in a hallucination.
That's what,
that's what the brain does,
is it creates a model of reality that is
that we live in.
We never experienced reality,
you know,
I mean we take it on faith really,
that there's some external reality out
there,
but everything comes to us through the
filter and is processed and extruded,
if you will,
into a more or less comprehensible most
of the time,
a model of reality and that's where we
live.
Reality is out there somewhere.
It's unknowable,
you know,
but we're getting signals through this
sensory neural interface and then the
brain is basically a processing a device
that takes that information,
combines it with internal associations
and everything and generates the
hallucination that you and I and
everybody else are living in at this
very moment.
You know,
we're all part of this constructed
reality.
So people dismiss it as psychedelic
experiences.
Hallucination,
I would say.
No it is,
but it's just another hallucination and
it's all hallucination.
It's all or at least interpretation of
something personal interpretation and
personal interpretation.
I mean the world physics.
We know enough through physics about
this supposedly external reality to know
that it doesn't look anything like what
we're experiencing,
you know,
it's all buzzing the electrons,
most of it's empty space.
This table is not solid.
It's mostly empty space.
It's soul energy and energy flexes.
We don't experience the world that way
most of the time.
Sometimes on psychedelics we do.
So maybe we're getting a,
an actual peak into the way it's really
constructed that,
you know,
we get to,
we get to look at the circuit board and
turn it over temporarily and look at it,
oh,
this is how it's wired.
You know,
this is the reality generating machine
that you get to look at when you strip
away,
uh,
you know,
the,
when you take the cover and look at the
way it's,
it's,
uh,
the diagram is wired.
Then you get some insights into it.
So then that's a useful thing because
then you can go back and you can say,
well,
none of this is real.
Let's not get carried away that,
you know,
this is any more real than anything
else.
And that seems to be like the,
the information that's coming from folks
that study subatomic particles,
that,
that inflammation is one of the most
undeniable pieces of information that
the universe is not what you think it
is.
It's not what you think.
It's just,
it's impossible for it to be what you
think it is.
When you study subatomic particles,
when you study things that can exist in
two places at the same time.
Like what are you talking about?
Like how they blink in and out of
existence.
What does that mean when they go away?
What do you mean to go away?
They go when they come back with the
fuck.
Are you saying go away and they come
back?
Are they here?
Are they not here?
Well they are and they're not.
Well they move.
Yes.
But they also stand still at the same
time was like superposition.
Like when someone.
I had Dr Goswami,
he's a theoretical physicist.
He tried to explain super position to me
and I was like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
It's moving.
And it's still at the same time.
Right,
right,
right.
What are you talking about?
Like what does that mean?
So here you have physics,
you know,
the absolute sort of cutting edge
science,
the one that we've charged with
explaining the fundamental nature of
reality.
And you talked to these people and it
sounds like the rates of schizophrenia,
it sounds like someone who's on drugs.
Yeah,
it doesn't deem.
It sounds like someone who may have the
mathematics and the measurements and all
that to back it up and say,
look,
I'm sorry,
this is how it is.
This what our math at our instruments
tell us if you want to trust that.
It's like we send a scout and the scout
went over the top of the hill and saw
the impossible.
Yeah.
And came back and go,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Don't go over there.
It becomes a rainbow that talks to you,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
that,
that is,
it's fascinating because the,
uh,
the explanations of reality by these
physicists are in fact more bizarre than
the experiences that are relayed by
people would take Iowasca.
Absolutely.
Those are way more believable than
particles and superposition or the fact
that it's all empty space.
Moving in a vibration.
And why do you know it's wood,
man?
What are you talking about?
This is would hear it and that's not.
I hit you over the head.
That shit's gonna hurt.
This is real.
There's no empty space there,
dude.
You're crazy.
But no,
that's.
That is what it is.
Yeah.
Well,
it's all real.
Yes.
Anything you experienced,
you can't dismiss it.
You can't say it's not real.
It's just not necessarily the absolute
reality and I don't know if there is an
absolute reality.
I agree with you and I think that's also
one of the transformative parts of the
psychedelic experience,
that the experience itself is
transformative because you're
experiencing it doesn't matter if it's
not real.
What does that mean?
It means nothing means nothing.
Not Real.
These are.
These are
dualistic delusions.
You know?
It's none of it's real.
It's all real.
So established,
established fact that when you get to
the lowest measurable portion of
reality,
when you get to subatomic particles,
it's fucking magic.
Okay,
so we go from there and then let's look
at.
Well,
it's all in your imagination.
let's look at what that means because
everything you see on this planet that a
human being has made has somehow or
other popped out of the imagination.
The imagination is a factory for
televisions and the Internet and
airplanes,
right?
Condoms and eyeglasses and laptops.
I mean the imagination is a motherfucker
and we have this idea that the
imagination is this frivolous thing.
Oh,
billy just sits in the field and
imagined what the world could be.
How about your dig a ditch,
billy,
how about you go to work billy,
hammer some nails and be a man.
Pull yourself up by your bootstraps and
stop crying because you're freaking out
about the fact that everything's air.
Everything is particles and it's all
know the whole thing.
Or are you sitting in a field and you
know,
you take LSD and you're steve jobs and
you have all these fantasies except that
you actually make it happen.
You create the apple computer or
whatever.
And that was a psychedelic vision and
was at the time and remained so,
and you know,
this thing here,
I mean this is the little psychedelic
toy of the future,
you know,
it's in my hand that it exists.
Will you ask it questions and it goes
online and it gives you the answer.
So the entire volume of human
understanding and that subject,
the consensus,
this is,
you know,
like where you were just explaining,
explaining what the chemical definition
of silicon is or the description of it.
You can find that out like that.
I had to go to you.
You're an expert.
You,
you came to me with your,
your education,
you explained it to me and.
But anyone can do that.
My phone just tapped into the database.
Yeah.
So that's some,
that's a threshold we've crossed in the
last decade or so where basically the
sum total of human knowledge is right
here.
And that's incredible for
transformation,
for creative thinking.
All of these things.
That's something we've never had before.
That and the conductivity.
The other thing is now there are 7
billion people or something like that on
the planet.
Well,
you know,
I don't know what the statistics are,
but 4 billion of them have cell phones,
you know,
so we've creating,
I mean,
they don't all have smartphones,
but they got some kind of a cell phone,
so they are tapped into this database
and that's making a big difference,
uh,
in the way that,
you know,
formerly disenfranchised populations
interact.
I mean,
you know,
you're a fish farmer and you have some
fish to sell.
You can go on your cell phone and say,
Oh,
well,
you know,
if I go to this village here,
I'll get a better price for that,
a trivial thing.
But in fact that decision affects
commerce on a global scale if enough
people are tapped into that.
Anyway,
your brother was obsessed with December
20,
first 2012 being some sort of a
transformative moment in our history.
And uh,
a lot of people were me included.
I guess we can put that one to rest,
I guess.
Can we.
That's,
that's one of the things that I've been
thinking.
Oh yeah,
yes,
as a specific day.
But if you really look at like the
tipping point of technological
technology and our connectivity and you
know,
that's kind of where it is,
whether it's 2008 or 2012 when you're
looking at a thousand years from now,
when they talk about the renaissance,
you know,
when they talk about,
uh,
you know,
what,
whatever great periods of,
of human history,
whenever a very gigantic periods of
change,
this is going to be one of the biggest
ever.
And it really,
really will boil down to these decades.
Are these at least these few years.
So his,
his error,
I thought as I was kind of a critic of
the timewave for exactly this I,
but for folks who don't know,
explain what that means,
that's his,
his idea that he created a mathematical
model based on each thing that he
claimed a describe the structure of
time.
I mean,
he postulated that time had to structure
and time had an end or at least history
had a damned and that that end was
December 20,
first 2012.
And there's a,
you know,
a linkages to the Mayan calendar which
supposedly said similar things.
It was,
it was a mistake to link it to a
particular day.
I think that's not the way that novelty,
the idea was that this wave described
the way that novelty in grest into the
continuum.
Well,
I think that novelty ingressives in the
continuum.
I mean everyday there's something new
under the sun.
There is something that never happened
before in the history of the universe.
It happens,
but it doesn't explode into the
continuum.
It more like it seeps into the
But change does happen.
And uh,
we're going through a,
a period of tremendous change,
but it's not linked to a particular day.
So what I say is he was wrong as far as
the particulars were concerned.
It wasn't December 20,
first 2012,
but he was totally right in terms of the
idea that novelty does increase and it
has increased and it's increased,
it's increasing them,
it's accelerating.
And all you have to do is look around,
you know,
and he was clearly right.
I mean,
if you look at where we are now,
even from where we were 10 years ago and
even 20 years,
can any of us even remember what it was
like 20 years ago?
You know,
I mean,
the world has completely transformed.
Yeah.
So he was correct in that sense,
you know,
that,
uh,
you know,
things are changing and well maybe in
just putting a date to it and giving
people something to focus on,
he made the idea more tangible for some.
It made it more tangible.
But I think it wasn't,
I think it was a,
not necessarily a good strategy because
it,
it people were giving into the
temptation of focusing on that date and
it was either on that date,
either everything's going to collapse
or,
or we'll cross the threshold and
everything will be great.
And it was kind of a,
you know,
consciousness will be transformed and
won't be in this golden state.
And I,
I thought it was kind of a,
uh,
for many people it was an excuse for not
taking responsibility.
I mean it and,
and just all we have to do is wait.
And then it'll all workout.
No,
you know,
that's not taking responsibility.
We've got to get cracking now.
We can't wait.
So now that it didn't happen.
So the message is the same.
We've got to get cracking and we can
relax.
Okay.
The aliens didn't land.
No wormholes appeared before our eyes.
Yeah.
None of that happened,
but it doesn't mean that things aren't
happening and you know,
uh,
to make things make change,
I think happened quietly,
you know,
they're not noticed.
They're not tremendous with,
with obvious exceptions like a global
asteroid impact.
I mean,
hey,
that's abrupt and it's transforming,
no doubt.
But that only happens once every few
million years.
Uh,
events normally don't explode into
history that way.
I mean,
tariffs used to talk about the,
you know,
the explode,
the first explosion of the atomic bomb,
you know,
well,
that was an abrupt event,
but not really.
I mean,
the.
When did the actual novelty take place?
Was it when Einstein developed the
equations that describe nuclear fusion?
Or was it the fishing rather?
Or was it the point where,
uh,
you know,
we achieved the first sustained nuclear
reaction.
I mean,
these were not things that anybody
noticed at the time,
but those were the transformative events
that made it possible to,
a couple decades later,
dropped the atomic uttama on the atom
bomb on Hiroshima,
you know,
and that's the one that got the
headlights,
but that wasn't really the roots of the
novelty,
if you know what I'm saying.
Yeah,
no,
I totally know what you're saying.
And it seems that they're all pile onto
each other as well,
pile onto each other and they're
cumulative.
Exactly.
And we haven't even started,
most likely.
No,
we haven't started.
Which is why the concept of an alien
invasion seems so ridiculous to us based
on our current capabilities,
but so inevitable.
When you think about the fact that we've
got robots wandering around on Mars
right now as we speak.
I mean,
what would we,
where would we think we're going to do?
I mean,
what we do,
the most spectacular thing we do,
we have two things we do.
We blow shit up and we explore space.
Those are the two things that gathered
the most attention,
right?
You know,
we can,
we can blow up a city or we can send a
robot to wander around on Mars and send
back videos and you're like,
Holy Shit,
those are the two very distinctly
different.
But this exemplify the limit
higher power.
Yeah.
We have the power to completely disrupt
the whole shooting match and just,
it all turns into radioactive slag or we
escaped some way and I think,
uh,
you know,
I think it's wonderful that we can send
robots to Maurice and all this,
but space is so fast.
It's never really gonna become
accessible to us unless we can figure
out this hyper light thing.
And I don't know if it's traveling the
traveling faster than light or figuring
out how to open up a portal.
I mean,
this idea that,
you know,
there's Tony Newtonian space separated
by this vast distances.
I don't buy it.
I think there's a way to get from one
place to another without going through
new to hyperspace as a real thing.
Well,
it might get down to,
to learn how to navigate it.
It might get down to we just have to be
stopped being carbon based life forms.
It might know that made it real space
travel.
Right.
It may end up that way too.
When you,
when you look at the possibility that
dimethyltryptamine and similar
psychedelics are a gateway to,
to some other thing,
whether it's another dimension and the
state of being another access to a part
of the mind that,
that doesn't,
doesn't exist.
Do you think that,
that.
Is that.
Is that something that I'm trying to
figure out how to say this,
but is that something that is like,
it's going to take a long time before
that's something that you could pass off
to other folks that haven't experienced
that and have them accept it and is
there a bridge to sort of,
uh,
getting them to consider these ideas?
Well,
I really,
I,
I don't know.
I mean the bridge,
the most convincing thing is,
you know,
here's,
here's the pipe,
smoke the pipe.
You don't need me to tell you.
As you mentioned before,
and it's quite true.
One of the beautiful things about
psychedelics is you don't have to have
faith,
all you have to have is courage.
You know,
you have to have enough courage to sit
down and put that pipe to your lips and
you know,
we can get beyond this conversation very
quick.
Yes.
Then we can have the real conversation
about what is all that mean,
what did,
what happened and what is the real,
what happened?
Are We,
you know,
are you a tapping into some external,
again,
these,
these ridiculous words that are
dualistic,
enhance,
you know,
but are you tapping into some dimension
that is not part of you or is it,
or are you looking at a,
you know,
a certain neurochemical brain state that
has,
that doesn't go beyond that.
And then it's like we can fall back on
what we were saying.
Everything you experienced isn't
neurochemical brain state,
right?
That's what we are.
That's what our brain does.
Um,
so do you define it yourself?
Like when you,
when you do it,
what do you think is happening?
DMT,
which is the most profound one
I think.
Well,
it's,
you know,
the problem with psychedelics,
one of the,
one of the problems that we experienced
with psychedelics is they are
essentially an English language bull.
They're beyond language and you take dmt
or something like that has such a
profound impact.
I mean,
you probably noticed it in yourself.
You're not even down from the experience
before.
You're trying to box it into some kind
of a linguistic box that's,
you know,
and you're reaching out and you're
babbling and then you're say that it,
that's it.
Or my God,
my God,
or you know,
but you're trying to put it into some
kind of a linguistic box because.
Because it's in comprehensible by nature
it seemed comprehensible.
It's like trying to describe what God
looks like it is by definition
undescribable and so,
but our brain wants to conceptualize
things.
So,
uh,
so whatever model you create of what it
is,
that's not it,
that's not the thing.
It's not what you experienced.
It's a memory of,
of what,
of what you experienced.
And uh,
uh,
I don't know how you get around that,
you know,
I think that,
um,
well,
I don't know.
It seems even exploring the concept
itself is almost impossible without the
experience almost
possible.
I mean it,
I mean,
so you're asking me to a supply,
a description.
So I,
with the caveat that any linguistic
description is going to be an adequate,
I would say a lot of what my impressions
of DMT are.
The most profound experiences are it
strips away.
You get to see the raw data,
the raw data of experience in the
unprocessed for,
you know,
how we were talking about how the brain
takes experience and,
and you know,
puts it all together into some kind of a
more or less comprehensible model.
And extrudes out has,
as you know,
your reality,
your movie,
the movie that your producer,
director and star of and uh,
it does that dmt gives you a chance to
kind of arrest that process.
And again,
as I said,
step back from it and look at the raw
data,
look at the circuitry underneath free of
interpretation and say,
Oh,
okay,
this is the,
this is the machinery.
This is the machinery that generating
reality.
But again,
by even saying that I don't do it
justice.
I mean it's,
it's slippery obviously it's a slippery
cock onset
intensely,
and I,
I've always wondered like what is the,
if there is a way to describe it to
someone who hasn't experienced and I
don't think,
I think there is,
and even to those of us who have
experienced it,
you can't describe it after my memory,
I had been tricked,
like that's not anything like Terence
Mckenna or Dennis Mckenna described it.
What did,
what was your experience like?
No self transforming machine elves.
Well,
I'm thinking of of my first mushroom
experience,
but now my first dmt experience was.
I mean it sounds trivial,
but it was sort of like some sort of
gingerbread or play dough that was alive
and talking to me and just sort of one
aspect of the godhead.
Just sort of gingerbread or playdough.
Yeah,
it was sort of like alive gingerbread
people I guess way it didn't look like
an Elf but it.
And it kind of had that,
that aspect.
Yeah.
It certainly felt alive like it had been
waiting for me.
Yeah.
That's the weird thing to see me.
The weird one is the friendliness of it,
but I felt dead.
That was my overwhelming feeling was,
oh no,
I've really done it.
But in the back of my mind I knew that I
was coming back.
I was still sitting in my chair and
before I knew it,
it was over and I was Doug Stan hope
who's a good friend of mine is a stand
up comedian.
Did a dmt with me the first time you
ever did it.
I had them over my house and he went
into convulsions,
which I've never seen before.
And W five meo and um,
he,
yeah,
he started moaning and foaming at the
mouth,
like he was,
like,
drool is coming out his mouth and he was
going,
oh.
And I was thinking of the Qti from this
shit.
I've never heard of anybody that's
fucked.
I just killed my friend.
Damn.
How am I gonna explain this.
And um,
I've never,
I've never seen anybody have that one
experience before or since.
And uh,
it was weird.
It was,
he was moaning,
it was a big dose.
He took a big dose and uh,
you know,
when he came back just for just filled
with descriptions that were inadequate,
you know,
which we all are,
but a five methoxy is even trickier.
DMT,
I don't know.
I mean I've had very limited experience
with firefox seat because it's too much.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I didn't think I was coming back.
That's my baby.
That's exactly the one we should be
looking into.
I mean,
I,
you know,
but it has more issues with toxicity and
all that and to uh,
but it's definitely puts you in this,
uh,
in this place to eat.
You know,
James horrocks book the trip to me
palace.
No.
Oh,
you should.
You might want to get him on this show
palace.
James Orac.
How do you spell it?
Oh,
R o
I see.
I believe five methoxy DM.
This is all about 5:00
ctmt that's this whole book.
Yeah.
And he says you think DMT is something?
Five methoxy is where it's really at.
And I can't dispute that because frankly
it scares the shit out.
It did.
It was different for me because,
um,
it didn't give me the sort of comfort
that dmt did,
that it was sort of talking to me and
communicating with me.
It was completely absent of any context.
It was impossible
play it.
That's what it was.
There were no,
no friendly Elfin,
no gingerbread people,
no machines,
no nothing like that.
It was like,
you were,
you were.
My apprehension was that was that I was
part of this oort cloud of souls.
I was a part of this somewhere somewhere
if there's a place where all conscious
entities arose from and go back to and I
was in the center of this galactic cloud
of,
of being,
you know,
um,
I mean I sort of had that diem awareness
of my existence as a separate entity,
but mostly I was part of this,
the soul
all out and a is the best I can describe
it,
you know.
And by the time I came back,
uh,
you know,
that was,
that was all completely faded as it
tended to.
That was,
that was,
uh,
that was 20 years ago that I had that
experience and still resonating with me.
I haven't done it.
Sam.
Yeah.
I've only had it a few times and I
didn't want to go back again.
I was like,
ah,
I got it.
I got that.
Whereas the on any time,
ethel trip to mean was a,
it was different every time and it
seemed like it was a communication,
like something was talking to me.
Like there was a lot going on.
The visual aspect of it was way more
compelling.
Yeah.
I did very little visual aspect with
foxy was just white.
Yeah.
It was like,
it felt like I wasn't,
I didn't have a consciousness anymore is
the only thing that I've ever done that
seemed to eliminate consciousness.
It wasn't,
didn't matter.
Like the vaguely aware the Dolly aware
of the fact that you exist at all was
one of the more terrifying aspects of
it.
It's like,
oh,
this is probably what happens when you
die.
When you die,
you probably go into this thing and
become whatever part of this cloud you
are
community of over souls,
which is every conscious being that ever
existed anywhere in the universe.
It also gave me the most tangible
feeling of there not being an up and
then not being in down.
There's no laugh.
There is no right or as the whole thing,
you know,
and then you're part of the whole thing
and it just goes everywhere.
It doesn't,
you're not in the middle,
you're not in the center,
you're not in the left,
not to the right.
It's just show the whole thing,
you know,
and you know,
it's an illusion.
And that,
that was the weird aspect of the planets
were an illusion that everything's a
little wind,
all of it.
Nonsense.
You're just a part of the whole,
when you get down to the lowest thing,
you're a part of the whole soup.
Yup.
He thought that drug,
he refers to a zero energy point feel,
uh,
which uh,
yeah,
I mean that's a definitely a,
a worth putting on your map.
And if you're brave enough or foolish
enough,
it's probably worth exploring.
But I'm,
I'm too old for that shit.
Right.
My friend Duncan took it and he took a
huge dose because he didn't believe it
was.
He had never done any dmt before and he
had done acid and I had never done acid
before.
And I was telling him about dmts.
I even ever even done acid.
So he takes a,
he takes dmt in a big dose and he calls
me up.
He's like,
what the fuck man?
I'm like,
I told you like,
no,
he didn't tell me.
You kind of told me,
but I didn't listen.
Right.
Holy Shit.
Like he was convinced that he died.
He was a believer.
Oh boy.
Was he ever.
Yeah.
It was a,
you know,
it's a very disturbing.
But again,
impossible to ignore transcendent
experience.
You know,
it is.
I think Salvia divinorum can take a
person to a similar space,
sort of.
You feel that you're,
you're no longer a point of
consciousness except it,
it doesn't feel like a cloud.
It feels like a Mexican dance party
or geometric thing,
isn't it?
Because it slipped through that Salvia
slip through and it took a while before
people realize that slipped through.
You mean legally speaking through
because it's,
its own best insurance against abuse.
Most people are like,
once there's enough,
never again,
one of these ones like five.
See,
I mean most,
some people do seem to be fascinated by
it and they keep going back to it and,
but most people find it very disturbing
and not,
not particularly enjoyable and actually
just,
just bizarro no.
But again,
these are areas,
uh,
of consciousness.
These pharmacological tools are,
are,
uh,
you know,
their exploratory probes into these
realms of consciousness.
And just because you're familiar with
the psychedelic experience,
which is mainly the tryptamine mediated
Serotonin,
you know,
dimension there all those other
dimensions out there and are aspects of
consciousness to Salvia divinorum
happens to be the kappa opiates.
You know,
it's a kappa opioid like end.
It's very selective for,
you know,
we don't think of opiates is going to
those places,
you know,
heroin and morphine,
those sorts of things.
They're euphoric,
gentle,
you know,
almost sedated states of mind kappa OPA
eight,
which is,
you know,
one of the three opiate receptors that
happens to be the one that's Salvia
divinorum exists.
It's a whole other ballgame,
you know,
I mean,
it's not a,
certainly not anything that anyone would
seek out,
you know,
certainly not addictive,
but so that realm of consciousness is
mediated by that whole network.
If you look at a,
the tourist,
the night shades,
the anticholinergics that's working on
Acetylcholine,
Acetylcholine blockers,
so that's a whole other neurotransmitter
system.
And if you look into,
you know,
the,
I may have a long history of use
obviously,
and they seem to be,
if you look into the use of tollway in
South America to weigh a brick band,
cea,
or you look at detour for another night,
shades in Europe.
This is the realm of race and ghosts and
that sort of thing.
Detour is a very interesting one too,
because of the,
uh,
the reality desolving properties of it
where people think that there's
somewhere that they're not,
and they have huge issues with memory.
You think that's the disruption of
Acetylcholine?
Well,
yeah,
it does,
it does disrupt memory.
We know that Acetylcholine has a lot to
do with the entrainment of memory and
detour,
detour.
It disrupts that.
So it's hard to remember the state,
which is probably a good thing because
the states are really bizarre.
Um,
I tell people detour it a night shade.
Detour is not a psychedelic,
but it's a true hallucinogen in the
sense that it's not a psychedelic state,
but you have hallucinations.
The problem is you can't tell if they're
real or not.
Usually a psychedelic hallucination,
you know,
it's not real.
You may be seeing something that's not
there,
but there's a part of your mind that's
saying this is a hallucination year.
It's not there.
You know,
you see things on detour.
You don't know if they're there or not
there,
you know,
you,
if I could,
I could have a hallucination.
I'm sitting across from you talking and
you see ms dot real and solid as you do
now.
You know,
but you're not there.
I'm having a conversation with you and
then you sort of just fade away like
kind of a wraith,
you know,
you sort of.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Where did you go?
Is that what has happened to you have,
you know,
that's what happens.
What happened to you when you did it?
That's what happened.
Like you were talking to someone.
They were.
They literally didn't exist.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I took a detour.
I described this in my book.
Actually.
I have old chapter of it,
a friend of mine and I took a detour up
when we were 16.
Not even knowing what it was.
I mean this is how clueless we were at
the time.
I actually thought it was a kind of
morning glory.
I,
I had had lsd once in my life and we
took this detour it.
I thought it was a different species of
morning glory.
So all this stuff began to happen and I
thought,
oh,
this is what a bad acid trip is.
Like wow.
And no,
it's not what a bad acid trip is like.
It's what a totally typical a detour.
A trip is like.
And it's characteristic that you see
entities,
you see things that are there.
And uh,
I was an and it was quite anxiety
provoking.
And uh,
my friend,
I was in my bedroom,
I managed to,
you know,
you have to read the chapter,
but I finally got to my bedroom,
I barricaded myself in my bedroom and my
mother was completely freaked out.
What was going on?
I just said,
mom,
how old,
you know,
I'll be out in 12 hours.
16.
Oh,
that's awesome.
And so I'm in the bedroom and one of the
weird things,
I guess people who take detours should
be for ward.
One of the things that does this dilate
your eyes,
right?
It's used medically to dilate your eyes.
Atrophying is what they put in your eyes
to do an eye exam.
What means is your
eyes are dilated so you can't see very
well.
And,
uh,
so any modeled surface anything with a
texture,
like a table cloth or wallpaper,
anything you're looking at starts to
swarm and step.
And the next thing you know,
they're bugs everywhere.
For me.
So it was like the bug experience.
There were insects,
all surfaces were covered with these
swarming,
you know,
things which were the visual distortions
of not being able to focus on anything,
but I was totally freaked out by this
and,
and so my friends or images of my
friends kept appearing at the edge of my
bed at the end of my bed and they would
appear and I would say,
help me,
get me out of here.
I'd be,
you know,
and they would sort of just look at me
and like,
you know,
you pour sand,
shake their head and then just fade
away.
That's awesome.
It's fascinating that it has something
to do with Acetylcholine.
Yeah.
Have you ever experimented with taking
acetylcholine before you go to bed?
Uh,
I haven't.
It's,
it gives you the most amazing lucid
dreams.
Amazing Dreams.
I'm not surprised.
Fascinating what I called durable lucid
dreams,
right?
Because I'm not a lucid dream.
I'm like,
I'm not disciplined in I,
I've never studied it.
I don't practice it.
Apparently there's techniques that you
can,
you can learn how to successfully lucid
dream on the Nash as it were,
but if you take acetylcholine before you
go to bed,
like a couple of hours before you go to
bed,
you have lucid dreams whether you like
it or not,
they're just more.
It seems like your dreams are more
durable when you're aware.
It meets me personally when I'm aware of
my dreams.
Normally they'd fade away like,
Oh,
I'm dreaming,
and then it's gone.
I wake up.
You're just boosting what's a natural
process because when you go to sleep,
your brain becomes flooded with
acetylcholine and these detours,
these,
these troll pain alkaloids,
what they do is block acetylcholine and
they block the receptors,
so their acetylcholine that called the
technical term is anti-cholinergic.
They block acetylcholine from binding to
its receptor,
so that's the basis of the altered state
of consciousness and interestingly
enough,
the detour a state of mind resembles it
resembles profound sleep deprivation.
If you keep yourself awake for five
days,
you will have experiences and
hallucinations that are almost
indistinguishable from a state of
deterrent intoxication.
That's bizarre.
I don't recommend it,
by the way,
I mean,
don't do Detroit or if you do deterrent,
have somebody there is looking after you
because you really can't distinguished
reality.
Um,
you do silly things.
Uh,
you know,
I had a friend who took the literal one
time and he spent the whole time a
dismantling his motorcycle engine on the
floor,
on his kitchen floor,
taking it apart and cleaning it and
putting it back together.
He didn't own a motorcycle.
Oh my God.
What if he learned how to do to do
it though?
What if you gave a motorcycle engine is
like,
Oh,
I've done this.
And then he starts doing it all the
other Uber Bizarre.
What is that?
Um,
there's that drug that they use for,
for air sickness.
Same One.
Scope.
Paula.
Me.
Yes.
That's the one.
That's the same thing.
That's Columbia Dental psychoactive
alkaloid in detour and Bella,
Donna,
and this is the one that does it.
There are other alkaloids,
but it's primarily sculpture.
And they used to use medically,
they used to use scope.
Paula mean because it's a for
childbirth.
Back in the days of barbarism when they
thought women in order to give
childbirth,
give birth,
had to be put in,
it had to be drugged,
you know,
they use Capella mean to put them in a
twilight state,
like a hypnotic state of semi
consciousness,
and then they could have the baby,
of course they didn't remember any
experience,
which was sort of the point,
I guess.
How does nicotine fit in?
Because one of my most intense,
lucid dreaming experiences with,
with a nicotine patch,
nicotine has the opposite effect to the
tropics.
Nicotine is what's the trope?
Answer what's called a acetylcholine
antagonists.
Nicotine is an agonist,
so it has an Acetylcholine like effect,
which is why when you smoke you get this
sort of cognitive activation,
you know,
it's great to settle down and focus your
attention on a task.
It activates cognition.
A lot of the research now on Alzheimer's
and other dementias are finding things
that either have this,
uh,
this,
this colon,
colon nurture jake,
a agonist effect like nicotine,
or they block acetylcholine from being
broken down their Acetylcholine esterase
inhibitors.
Acetylcholine estrace is the insight in
that breaks down acetylcholine.
I don't smoke cigarettes,
but I,
um,
I found it absolutely fascinating
reading Stephen King's book on writing
where he talked about when he stopped
smoking cigarettes.
It really affected his writing process.
Absolutely.
I'm not surprised she didn't,
you know,
didn't really fire up the way he is.
That's right.
Yeah.
So now we've again got off the track and
we're off in the jungles of
pharmacology.
No,
it's fascinating.
I mean,
it's off track at all.
it's all interesting because it's all in
relationship to what we understand
currently about compounds that affect
the human body and what you're doing
with the ethno botanical stewardship
council is to try to educate people on
these things,
try to expand consciousness and
awareness of these things and really
just just promote it and put energy
behind it.
[inaudible],
part of it is education.
It's developing a model of self
regulation that can,
can improve the safety of people that
want to use these traditional plants.
But one thing I want to be clear about
is that we're ourselves not setting a
standard per se.
We're engaging people in dialogue,
we're kind of setting the table for
indigenous groups and people that run
retreat centers,
people that are selling Iowasca online,
etc.
All the people that are involved in the
kind of value chain of iowasca to come
together and determine,
well,
what is sustainability at the site level
look like?
Like ecotourism,
how are you giving back to the
community,
to the biodiversity of the place where
you're,
where you have your site,
how are you making sure that people in
the ceremony are safe,
that they're screen psychologically or
for heart conditions.
They're not tAking antidepressants,
they have a people babysitting or
watching,
so people don't wander off into the
jungle.
The antidepressants wants is an
interesting one.
What,
what's the issue with that?
Well,
the issue with antidepressants and
iowasca is [inaudible].
Iowasca involves mao inhibitors,
right?
and so,
uh,
it prevents the breakdown of dmt,
right?
And the butt.
And so there's a lot of dmt in your
suit.
It's a serotonergic agonist,
right?
And so are the antidepressants.
So you are essentially piling on one
sarah to nurture agonist on another
cause you're inhibited.
And the breakdown process,
man is involved in breaking down both
dmt and serotonin,
so the,
the safety wise,
the issue is that it could lead to
what's called a serotonin syndrome.
And the serotonin syndrome is something
that happens when you got too much
serotonin,
too much,
uh,
pushing the serotonin button a little
bit too hard and it can lead to
hyperthermia and a cardiac,
your regularities and,
uh,
ultimately death if it's really bad,
you want to avoid the serotonin syndrome
if possible.
That's fascinating because that's also
an issue that people have if they take
an ssri and they want to consume
tryptophan or five htp.
Exactly,
exactly.
That's also a one way to do it.
And in some ways the psychedelic
experience itself is kind of skirting
this.
I mean,
you're,
you're pushing the serotonin button,
right?
But in most cases with psychedelic you,
you haven't inactivated the instamatic
breaks that are,
that are metabolizing this stuff.
So It's not an issue with iowasca,
it's,
it's really only an issue if you're
taking an ssri or if you're taking mao
inhibitors,
which most people,
they're not used clinically anymore.
there was a whole older generation of
antidepressants that are mao inhibitors.
You shouldn't,
you shouldn't combine those with iowasca
and you shouldn't combine ssrs with
iowasca.
The,
that may be a theoretical hazard.
There's,
I haven't seen a lot of reports of
serotonin syndrome happening with
iowasca.
Um,
but so it's a theoretical hazard,
but I'm sure there are people taking
serotonin uptake inhibitors that are
taking iowasca given there is no
problem,
but they're probably taking lower doses.
It's just a good idea to get off those
things.
Before you take iowasca,
is it a good idea to get off those
things,
period?
Yeah,
I mean is if you can,
if not for every day really helped some
people,
but yeah,
but a lot of times,
uh,
you know,
antidepressants are over prescribed and
overused for too many things.
They don't,
they don't really help people get to the
root of their problems.
They just kind of bandaid it over and
you feel sort of normal,
you know,
and you can be a productive citizen and
you don't really think about things too
much.
They're prescribed for ptsd,
you know,
but they don't cure ptsd.
They just kind of dampen it down and
bury it.
They don't give you an opportunity,
uh,
to really,
you know,
look at issues and work them through.
This is why psychedelics or not a good
model for big pharma.
Big pharma wants things like ssri,
which you take everyday for the rest of
your life.
That's the business model.
Psychedelics are things that you might
take a few times and work through your
issues and you don't need
antidepressants.
After that.
I've talked to many,
many people who said,
you know,
who have been on antidepressants.
They go to south America,
they take a few iowasca sessions.
They never have to go back to
antidepressants again.
I mean,
they can get off at for good.
Many people have that experience.
That's a huge problem financially for
pharmaceutical companies as well.
You don't see him pilate on exactly what
they need to start selling iowasca yeah.
Yeah.
It's not gonna work that way because big
pharma,
they want drugs that people consume.
I think the way that.
I think one of the business model,
you can't use these drugs in therapy in,
in a therapeutic session without intense
psychotherapy,
whether,
whether that's actual psychotherapy or
shamanism or some combination of those
things,
these are drugs that have to be used in
context,
know the,
you know,
the take two and call me in the morning
model doesn't work for these.
These have to be used in a very highly
controlled set and setting.
So I think where they,
uh,
where the business model come see it is
you have places where people can go and
get this kind of therapy.
So it shifts from the drug itself.
The emphasis is,
uh,
you know,
our whole biomedical industrial complex
is set up to encourage bandaid
solutions.
You know,
you have a problem,
you go see your psychiatrist,
he has seven minutes.
If he's lucky to talk to you,
here's the prescription,
get out of here.
You know,
that's the way it works with
psychedelic.
He actually have to have a therapist who
will sit down and talk with you.
This whole novel concept and uh,
you know,
so I think where the business potential
comes in is that to,
to have centers of therapy where you
couldn't go and get psychedelic therapy
and the emphasis is more on the setting
and the services provided than the
actual chemicals.
Yeah.
The setting and the,
uh,
the,
the new this is possible in other
countries where it's legal in America
started happening in America right now.
It's a huge issue.
But josh was talking about selling
iowasca online.
I mean,
how many people do that in?
What's the Legality when it comes to the
plants themselves are not necessarily
illegal.
Right?
Right.
Dmt is illegal.
Dmt is illegal,
but dmt is found in so many plants that
uh,
you know,
they,
they can't really make all those plants
illegal because,
you know,
I mean,
they can,
but they're not going to be able to
enforce it.
Then it's going to be able to have
salad.
Literally.
You're not going to be able to have
salad.
I mean,
I'm,
you know,
hearkening back to what we were saying
about how close dmt is to tryptofan two
steps away.
I'll bet you,
I mean,
I,
I wish somebody would do this,
there's no funding for this,
but I'll bet you if you had sufficiently
sensitive instruments,
you could find dmt in all plants.
You know,
you could just start randomly selecting
them out of your backyard and run them
through the mass spec or whatever.
You could pick up dmt.
Not in usable amounts,
but it's universally just nature is
drenched in dia.
Why do you think that is?
Because it's so close to trip to fan,
you know,
and it's just the,
the compound tryptofan is universally
distributed.
The enzymes that transform it to dmt
have other cellular functions.
So they're found in all cells.
They're just part of metabolism and so
it's just an accident of nature,
you know?
it's just,
it's just the way it is.
What a fascinating war.
It's actually maybe nature's trying to
send us on a little message if you want
to interpret it that way,
but it's just the way it is or it's just
a part of the building blocks of the
universe itself.
Part of the building blocks of.
Exactly,
exactly.
And that,
that chemical doorway to another
dimension exists in virtually everything
that's alive.
What a mind fuck that is selling iowasca
uh,
online.
I don't know if uh,
I don't know if people are selling
iowasca prepared a iowasca bruce online
are,
seems to be the kid in a gray area.
yeah.
I think that's irresponsible because.
Well,
because it's a,
it's a drug that needs to be taken and
an appropriate sentence setting.
It needs guidance.
So to sell it online is to be guilty of
that whole thing.
Take two and call me in the morning,
go off and do this with your friends.
Well that's what went out in the
operation and,
and the any real knowledge.
So that's,
that's not ethical in mind
opinion.
That's how five mio is acquired until
fairly recently when I bought five.
I mean,
you know,
I just bought it online.
It's just delivered me enough to get the
world high.
yeah,
I mean it was a little,
I mean it,
you realize how potent it is and what a
small dose he need.
And if they're sending you some giant
supply of it,
well that's an issue with,
with all of these things and the whole,
you know,
the whole designer drug thing,
there are,
you know,
hundreds and hundreds of these things.
So I sort of say,
well,
you know,
we should stick with the plants.
At least we know what the identity of
that.
But,
you know,
I mean,
I think that,
synthetic drugs are out there.
People are going to use them.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
it,
it comes back to education,
to teach people how to,
how to use drugs.
Basically you have to teach people how
to use drugs.
This is what so called drug education
has,
won't quite,
hasn't quite grok to,
hasn't quite admitted,
but that is in fact,
that's real drug education,
not,
you know,
all drugs are bad.
Never take it.
I mean,
that's absurd.
That's now you've
lived through several errors of
psychedelic awareness.
you lived through the sixties,
you live through all that craziness.
He lived through the seventies,
you lived through the clamp down and now
you're here,
which is,
I think it's safe to call this the
psychedelic renaissance.
I think this is.
This is a new time when we'd like to
think so I.
I'm pretty positive.
At least it isn't my reality there.
The reality that I experienced,
I mean I've never in my time seen
psychedelics more reference than I see
them today and part of it's because the
company I keep part of it is because the
message that I put out and the people
that I interact with because of that,
but I think also it's just a.
It's just a matter of the cat got out of
the bag.
The stigma
is fading away.
The whole sixties baggage that
psychedelics have been have been
marginalized with for so long that's
going away and a new more positive
perception is appearing as some of these
therapeutic uses are becoming more aware
in general consciousness.
So ptsd can be treated with mds,
mtma.
We've got veterans out there who need
that.
That's a hugely powerful message and if
the department of defense is behind it,
it can't be bad.
Yeah.
I mean,
isn't that kind of ironic that the need
for psychedelics has arisen from the war
culture that we totally ironic,
but so strange.
There it is.
And so these positive messages are being
hurt more and more and there's less and
less a sort of,
you know,
partly because a lot of people from the
sixties are dying off or whatever they
don't remember,
but the knee jerk negative message about
psychedelics is not happening this
month.
Yeah.
There's,
they're much harder to distinguish now.
The folks who use them then the hippies
with the beads and the,
you know,
the,
the look which was so stereotypical of
what,
you know,
the goldwater republicans found
reprehensible about that generation.
They were lazy,
shiftless do for nothing.
People that just wanted to get high and
escape reality and that,
that,
that paradigm that,
that perception is passing.
Yeah.
That's all to the good.
What has it been like for you to
experience these different waves?
Well,
uh,
I don't know.
I haven'T really been personally
impacted by this,
this thing,
you know,
I mean,
I've been where I've been all the way
through and not particularly public.
I'm much more public now about it than I
have been.
So I may,
maybe that's a difference.
Uh,
but I don't feel that I have to be
careful about talking about it in
public.
I mean,
I'm,
I consider myself an advocate for
responsible use,
you know,
and good science.
And I'm not even saying people should
even take these things take,
you know,
what I'm saying is that if you decide to
take it,
go into it with open eyes,
do some preparation,
pay attention to set and setting do it
in a way that,
you know,
if there are benefits to be had
maximized the benefit.
So approach it as a conscious,
a conscious exercise and uh,
you know,
um,
and,
and approach them with respect and in
intention.
These are serious thing.
What do you say to someone who has zero
experience and he thinks I'm gay.
I guarantee you right now this podcast
is reaching people that have no
psychedelic experience whatsoever.
They don't know anyone who has had any
psychedelic experience.
They don't know where to turn or where
to start,
but they're very intrigued and the
door's been open to them.
Well,
the first thing to do is get yourself
educated about it,
you know,
like sign up for this symposium.
I mean watch the online thing,
but there are many other tools.
Uh,
another group that I love to plug and I
think they're doing a marvelous work is
erowid.org.
It's online.
It's the best online source of
information about psychoactive drugs,
of all kinds,
not just psychedelics.
It's the go to place on the web.
If you want real solid information,
not bullshit,
not put out by the propaganda put out by
people who,
whose commitment is to accurate
information.
Start there.
It's fantastic.
Read about it.
There are trip reports,
there were safety reports that
chemistry,
the,
you know,
uh,
the field botany,
the part of it that the shamanic
traditions,
it's all represented there.
That's the place to start spelling out
to for p,
r o w id erowid.org.
Go there and read up about it.
Educate yourself before you take the
substance so that you can make an
informed decision,
uh,
what's an appropriate method of use?
Uh,
what are the right circumstances?
What are the hazards?
What do you not want to do?
I think that's the first thing.
And I,
I think,
again,
I think this symposium,
a conference is gonna be great,
but it's also exemplary of what needs to
happen.
And I'm really impressed that,
you know,
young people like the folks that are
organizing this conference or are
stepping up to the plate and saying,
we want to make this a part of
education,
an educational dialogue.
We want to have this happen on lots of
university campuses.
Lots of places.
That's the thing we have better now than
we've ever had for sharing the
information.
Take advantage of those tools.
Uh,
you know,
before back in the sixties,
seventies,
you might not have had no experience
with psychedelics and no real,
uh,
you know,
no way to know how am I going to find
out about these things.
You know,
now it's a click of a mouse and you're
there,
and now there's no excuse for not
educating yourself.
Another very good site is ice
[inaudible] dot org,
I c e r s the international center for
ethnobotanical ethno botanical education
research and service based in europe.
They have a ton of information about
iowasca boga,
the plant based psychedelics.
There also a sort of incubation partner
for the esc,
helping esc.
Ibogaine is another fantastic drug for
dealing with addiction.
Uh,
I have a good friend who had a back
injury and got hooked on pain pills and
had a real problem and really couldn't
kick it.
Uh,
wenT to Mexico,
did ibogaine,
became completely fascinated,
cured,
and absolutely fascinated by obligation.
And how is this possible that this is
escape?
Western medicine started his own.
Um,
I became a center down there and now,
you know,
regular.
I mean,
he's just a different human being.
When I talked to him,
he's just so at peace and just,
it's a different guy.
He knows himself in a different way.
[inaudible],
it breaks that physical addiction to
opiates.
Instantly the esc is of signing a
memorandum of understanding with the
global ibogaine therapists alliance to
work on the safety and the
sustainability of that traditional
plant.
It's under extreme pressure from the
growing global demand.
It's traditionally from africa and it
takes seven years for a mature plant to
be grown and then you have to take the
root out and you kill the plant.
So,
um,
there's a lot of Work to be done.
Um,
there's a,
a global ibogaine therapist alliance
conference in durban,
uh,
this may as well we're hoping to have
some big announcements come out of that
on the sustainability front.
So many things came out.
Again,
it was,
it never went away.
It was always there,
but it a,
you know,
it was suppressed essentially in western
medicine.
I mean they had a perception that it had
no place.
There were almost clinical studies
approved by the fda and then they
stepped back from it because of some
supposedly neuro toxicity,
which I don't think they ever
satisfactorily demonstrated.
But that's a good example.
You know,
the therapeutic community was saying,
well,
I gave is so useful for this addiction
therapy that we're just not gonna put up
with this.
and so I began as not illegal.
It's illegal in the states,
but it's not in most of the world.
So these addiction treatment centers
have blossomed all over the world.
There's Mexico,
south America,
even Canada.
There are treatment centers that use
ibogaine to treat addiction and they've
just said,
well,
you know,
fuck the fda,
we're going to step outside that
framework and do it because it's
important to get this therapy to people
and that's all to the good.
I think that's a model maybe for what's
going to happen with iowasca.
Yeah,
I would hope so.
And I would.
I would like to see what's going on
right now with marijuana in this
country.
Slowly started happening with iowasca,
ibogaine,
psilocybin,
all the,
all these various things.
Um,
do you have hope for that?
Totally.
I do.
History is on our side.
And first thing I'd tell people that are
considering psychedelics is put your
preconceptions aside and just look at
the facts.
What would you say that
someone say,
look,
we're talking about young people.
What if a guy's 50 and you know,
maybe he's going through a rough divorce
and uh,
you know,
I was like,
man,
this fucking I need to reset my brain.
I need to figure this out,
but I don't know anybody.
Nobody at the office knows anything
about this stuff.
Right?
Well,
a smoked a joint in college.
That's about it.
Take it in a traditional context that
you feel comfortable with.
Take it in a.
If you're looking for psychological
help,
maybe take it at a center that focuses
on that if you want to,
if you've always been attracted to
shamanic experiences,
then suss out which centers might be
best for you and read revIews of them.
And in two to three years the esc will
have a rating system or kind of star
rating system for sites based on how
sustainable they are,
how safe side psychedelics is.
Not so much a yelp or a deeper level
than a yelp because they can't fake it
though you can't take it,
but it's hard for somebody going in to
see what kind of an impact a center has
on the local community or where they're
sourcing the iowasca come from,
comes from and that's where we're,
the esc is bringing that professional
expertise to,
to supplement what the community is
doing.
Um,
and certainly we will rely on feedback
from visitors that will be part of the
credibility and the transparency that
we're building into the way of assuring
the sites are sustainable and safe or be
grievance mechanisms.
If you have a bad experience,
hopefully in five years,
five,
that's probably optimistic timeframe,
but hopefully in 10 years they'll be
places you can go and have these
experiences where you don't have to
leave the country.
I mean,
you can already find them outside the
country,
but it would be nice if there were
places in the states where you could get
this and it would,
it would transform a psychiatric
medicine.
Uh,
if there was,
which is again,
threatening to many people with a stake
whole estate
in how it's done now,
but I talked to so many,
um,
psychiatrists,
other professionals that are involved in
the mental health world.
They're very frustrated.
They're like,
say these people are hurting and the way
that we're handling them is not solving
the problem.
It's only making it worse.
Um,
so,
you know,
there needs to be a wholesale,
I wouldn't say overturning,
but transformation of the model.
I,
um,
I think that we're on the right track.
I really do.
I'm,
there's a lot of people that are cynical
today and they look at today's culture
and they look at the toxification of our
environment and the materialism and the
nonsense on television.
They see it as a bad sign.
But,
uh,
I really feel like civilizations
cramming.
Yeah,
I really do.
I really think we're just scrambling to
try and maybe we need something like all
this nonsense that we experience on a
daily basis to sort of really motivate
this,
this global awakening.
We have to consume it to the extent that
we're sick of it,
that it makes us sick,
and then we purge the iowasca bottle.
We consume so much of it that eventually
you just regurgitate it all and you feel
much better afterwards.
You know?
Yeah.
I think that's partly what we're doing.
I think the most exciting thing too is
that we have a way out or we have a way
up.
Whereas like it's not like we're in this
pit and there's no ladder,
like there's a fucking lie.
Hey,
we have,
we have the tools.
I mean,
and they're incredibly profound and
real,
you know,
these aren't theoretical things like,
we have a lot of these theoretical
concepts about like fixing the plastic
in the ocean.
Well there's,
you know,
some 19 year old kid figured out a way
that there's a machine.
It scoops it up.
Then it converts it into something
usable.
Then we could use that for energy.
And the same thing's true with nuclear
waste.
There's some theories about how to.
But those are all.
Those are theoretical.
They may or may not be effective.
They may or may not ever get built.
The ladder is not be in your life right
there.
Let's,
you know,
I mean,
in respect to that,
we look at this dire existential
situation,
the environmental crisis and all that.
I take heart in the notion of never
underestimate human ingenuity.
You know,
there are a lot of really smart people
working on all these problems and that's
my hope,
you know,
for our survival,
I think that the ingenuity will prevail.
I hope so,
because otherwise we're in.
I mean,
we're already in deep shit.
The question is how do we,
how do we dig out of it?
And uh,
it,
you know,
that's why we have these smart brains,
we're not going to get there by being
stupid.
We've had of that and there's still
plenty of it to go around and.
But we need to move beyond that,
you know,
stop listening to a lot of people,
like our politicians,
for example,
who seemed to make a profession of
stupidity and they're actually proud of
their stupidity.
And that's distressing in any way.
In what way do you feel like that would
be like sarah palin mean people like
that,
you know,
the science deniers,
the people that,
you know,
I don't,
don't bother me with your fucking facts.
You know,
my mind is made up and you know,
when god told me this and you know,
this is horseshit.
I mean,
come on,
you know,
clear thinking at least should be a
criteria and if you want to be a
politician,
not somebody who's,
you know,
a buying into some,
some myth from the 14th century.
I don't necessarily even think most of
them are buying into it.
I think what they've done is realize
that there is a market for that.
There's just a gigantic chunk of the
population is terrified of change,
terrified of the possibilities,
the unknown,
the intangibles.
And they would like something norman
rockwell,
they would like you to paint some really
clear and easy to recognize a pattern
that they could see.
Jesus,
thank you jesus.
You know,
and they just jumped.
The lord has blessed me in so many ways
and they just fucking locked themselves
in this box of perception.
And then politicians come along and they
go,
oh,
that guy,
I know how to fucking play his
heartstrings.
Exactly.
You're part of the problem.
You're not really helping solve the
problem.
You're taking advantage of what these
people,
what I think even karl rove called
useful idiots.
People that want simple answers,
I call them simple answers for simple
people.
Hey,
get over it.
There are no simple answers,
you know,
and what we need to be doing this
looking for the real answers,
asking the hard questions,
realizing that it's solve very
complicated.
There are answers,
but we're not going to get there through
delusions and fairy tales.
You know,
we've got to actually acknowledge and
start thinking about this and start
talking about it to other people in a
real way.
So sarah pailin these people in these
mushrooms,
they're idiots.
He's iowasca.
She needs a dmt trip that she needs a
head with transplant.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
she would,
she would realize that she's right and
wrong at the same time.
Mind blown.
And um,
okay.
So the website,
uh,
for uh,
for the ethno botanical stewardship
council,
it's ethno botanical council.org
and the,
um,
the symposium is spelled sim like as in
psychedelic p,
s y symposium 2014.
It is April 12th and 13th in amherst,
Massachusetts.
Listen folks,
you've got to make it the upside of this
symposium.org
or symposium symposia.
Simpler jose.
A.org.
Yeah.
And if you could make it there,
beautiful it can you pay to go there.
$30 out the door,
$20 in advance tickets,
a $30 at the door if you actually want
to go.
But you can also watch it live for $10
online deal deal.
It's a,
it's a great deal.
And you are contributing to something
that is hugely important.
You are part of this whole movement.
There's something going on folks.
Uh,
dennis,
you're a huge part of it.
Josh are a huge part of it.
The people listening to this podcast are
a huge part of it.
It's all out there and it's moving.
It's moving in,
I think a good direction.
I really do
one last plug if I made.
There's a congress that I'm going to
next weekend in Mexico to luca,
a bringing together indigenous leaders
with a boga,
a pod,
mushroom,
a iowasca experience,
and they need funding to attend to bring
more of the,
the traditional healers to that
conference.
It's called the the second international
congress on traditional medicine and
public health,
sacred plants,
culture and human rights.
And is this information all available on
ethno botanical council.org?
Can you.
Can they find it there?
No,
but I'll change that in the news
section.
So what the hell?
What the fuck?
Come on man.
We're all working together on this
kitchen.
Say it.
Well,
I'd like to say joe also,
thank you for having us on and you,
you my friend are one of the change
makers for sure.
Don't underestimate that.
I mean you're,
you're a hero of my.
Oh,
that's a huge honor.
I'm a useful idiot.
What I am is a no idiot.
I'm a repeat or have things that are
fascinating,
but I appreciate that very much and I
feel as compelled,
as all of you to try to broadcast as
much of what I've stumbled upon and,
and talk about it as much as possible
and it's impossible without guys like
you.
So thank you all.
Thank you very much.
Thank you everybody listening to thank
you for having us thank you to the list
or we're all in this shit shit together.
People.
So,
uh,
please go to ethno botanical
council.org.
Go to symposia with p,
s,
y symposia.org.
And uh,
that's it.
We'll be back next week with much more
love,
big kiss till then.
Wow.
Three hours.
What time is it?